ce nouveau match de ce pitch est féminin
fitch est féminin match qui oppose
valentina goulinat à irin accroche et
j'avais noté leur palmarès est gelé plus
j'ai été sur le téléphone c'est un peu
c'est un peu brouillon autour de moi
mais valence et sabrina qui a été
championne du monde de blitz en 2012 je
crois
championne de russie à plusieurs
reprises championne d'europe gros
palmarès
irina crush qui a surtout brillé aux
états unis avec plusieurs à plusieurs
titres de championnes aussi et donc
c'est un beau match qui s'annonce
mais je vais vous récupérez le jeu façon
j'ai sur mon mobile
le palmarès mais je crois que ces
championnats du monde 2012 gouina si je
ne m'abuse et d'ombrés vous en photo
normalement elle est favorite on sait
qu'elle joue vite elle joue avec mon pro
de chasse league donc on va pas on va
pas faire de suspense on va être pour
valentina voilà pas de pas de suspense
de toute façon ça donne toujours un
petit peu d'intérêt d'être pour pour une
joueuse et je dis bonjour à tous bonjour
à l'ombre de quais bonjour abba bonne
joueur magique coating on jouera brisage
je vais vers une peu de seconde j'ai je
vais mettre le hosting c'est quand même
beaucoup plus facile à faire avec le
téléphone
alors les pseudos des joueuses gouina en
plus ce truc c'est qu'elle joue avec
nous ah mais je vais la voir en ami
willy n'a de toute façon si je la trouve
ces vanina son pseudo de mémoire enfin
c'est et vanina son pseudo pu tâter à la
changer de pseudo dans vanina 1989 voilà
elle est là on va pas pouvoir mettre un
flou pour le moment ça passait pas
encore parti mais je vais faire ça très
vite puisque après je vais oublier
j'avais oublié pour un match de le faire
parce que je sais qu'il ya des gens qui
veulent regarder sur la chaîne bitstream
pour être sûr de pas rater et donc je
vais le mettre ici je relirai le chat
mais ça
c'est le cas pas oublié de faire ouais
ça c'est fait salut à grace à salut à
nico mnb elle salua ridha 8 ca pas mal
de monde aujourd'hui je vois que le
match vous vous intéresse vous êtes
nombreux
je vois que vous êtes nombreux les amis
je vois au nombre et ce soir y aura
aussi la reina blitz prix mais ça on
aura le temps d'en reparler à 22h on
fera une petite arena bitstream d'une
heure on enchaînera tout de suite avec
inscrit un stream sur la chaîne
bitstream en fait directement mais je me
dis qu'il ya des figuiers fille alors
pour une fois ça nous intéresse est
magique aux tic
on sait plus ou moins qu'il en couple
mais bon il fait sous couvert de venir
regarder des échecs
aïe aïe aïe c'est plus ce que c'était
salade cigale comme maxime salua uleb
barbatruc salut à eric et ramzy eux ils
sont 2 saluer le charpentier salah bundy
fr le champion avec un petit soudan le
chat à illéla le charpentier il se met
un petit is who is who et
malheureusement on parle un peu de tout
et dort et en attendant le match
vous connaissez maintenant
malheureusement l'objectif des 300 ce
qui sera pas atteint avant la date
butoir du 30 mai pour poursuivre le
norwich est ce donc petite déception
vous avec l'iss à l'uqam in the stream
pas le top-12 ya fab foot us et si je
vais stream et tous les tournois que je
vous fais poser que je passerais ma vie
à suivre les toura de fab
je passais ma vison legear l'ordinateur
à regarder les parties de femmes n'ont
donc non en tout cas si les baisses sont
pas les mêmes c'est perturbant ouais je
suis d'accord écoute c'est pas moi qui
décide ça l'échiquier bleus pourquoi pas
mais mais bon tu pourrais mettre dans le
chatt leur pseudo bah écoute quand je
les aurai enfin vanina ses seins parce
que c'est me vanina 1989
mais en fait tu vas on va les voir
apparaître à l'écran une fois qu'elles
commenceront à jouer les pseudos salut
skyward salut à glace un glass un tout
que tu glisses in to cut
on ne sait pas salut qu'à oumma et ya
pas mal de monde là ce soir qu'est ce
qui se passe près du monde ce soir on ne
sait pas et jeudi aura le match 2 de
marie ce bail mais loin d'être
concentrés les joueuses de marcel ça
joue pas ça le psycho 1616 1110 maïs et
chômage est là et complètement pourquoi
que les 18 heures on ne sait pas on ne
sait pas on me dit que ça joue à tous
même spéciale si ça joue jamais tari
flèche un refresh parce que ça s'affiche
pas pour moi mais peut-être c'est un
petit bug technique c'est tout à fait
possible une fois que je retrouve à nina
allez c'est exact c'est parti c'est
parti vanina qu'ils allaient blanc pour
la première partie donc si vous voulez
les pseudo c'est vanina avec les blancs
contre 1989 contre heroes chica donc
irina il refusa choix qu'il est
d'origine ukrainienne de mémoire 83 ans
est soigné de naissance encore une info
qui n'a pas été vérifié tout ça ça et ça
craint donc le cas de ces cinq élèves
trois des six ça ok ah ok donc elles
jouent pas qui les prends des cachets ça
me prend des quatre à six fours et ça
donc c'est une variante jeu pas son
peuple et sa check over aussi mais en
gros ça évite s'est vite les grandes
variantes la stabilité nador ça vite un
tas de trucs et c'est tout à fait
jouable est donc là on se retrouve avec
un genre de hérissons phare hérisson oui
un genre de avec cette structure le pion
d66 comme de recherche d'un guidon qui
contrôlent pas mal le centre un contrôle
beaucoup de cases mais il ya un problème
d' espaces les noirs qui sont un peu
resserré
il joue en gros sur trois rangées quand
les blancs peuvent eux occupés
facilement quatre ans j'ai donc à une
rangée de plus pour les blancs quelque
part c'est l'avantagé d'avoir les blancs
mais en contrepartie de sa du problème
d'espacé les noirs se sont pas créé de
faiblesse et donc ils vont essayer de
pousser un jour des 5 ou hockey venir
peut-être chanter un peu versé 4 passant
par à 500 prend d'opio 4 avec le fouet
de cavalier peut mettre une tour ans et
8 pour jouer la colonne c'est une tour
en des huit admettons ramener la dame
perd à 8
ça c'était possibilité est le truc c'est
que les blancs ils n'ont pas vraiment de
point d'appui en allégeant combien de la
fidh
alors bonne question c'est est affiché à
l'écran vanina qui au dessus de 2005
alors qu'elle est loi là exactement je
sais pas maintenant mais elle avait dans
les 25 30 mais je peux je peux vous dire
ça le vélo exact je peux vous le donner
assez facilement gouny là parce que le
vélo de gouina qui avait un peu baissé
je sais puisque je joue avec elle en
produit s league donc quand je fais les
conquois les 25 06 madrelle a encore
baissé par rapport à par rapport à
septembre dernier elle a été à 25,48
donc 25 06 elle va bientôt jouer les
candidats féminin enfin les candidates
du coup et irina crush irina crush irina
creusons qui est bien né en 83 et qui
est 2451 donc 24 heures je mangerai 10
24 30 25 20 et ses essais 24 50 25 1 0
match olala encore encore le mec de
fortes light alors j'ai réussi à
rajouter ludwig ans en modérateur
honnêtement j'ai tellement de choses à
faire j'ai réussi à trouver comment
faire la manip mais j'ai mis que ludwig
je n'ai pas mis 2 mais franchement
fortnight enfin forte nietzsche j'ai
envie de dire c'est exagéré donc
cavalier e st loup comme je disais elle
va se bouger par la case 2,4 alors la
question peut se poser ce cavalier prend
pions prend j'ai envie de dire ça fait
des pions doublet mais c'est des pions
doublé qui vont contrôler un maximum de
case centrale et sur la colonne eux donc
ils sont pas si mauvais et en plus il
peut y avoir une petite question sur ce
pion de quatre noms peut-être ferait
reculer sur la case de 3 je suis en
train de me demander ce que cavalier
prend 4 est jouable mais bon j'imagine
qu'au pire ya juste
et prend le cas doit pas marcher ici je
vais voir jusqu'à vallée prend 2,4 et
surtout prend g5 comprend du cavalier et
surtout prend 2,4 on prend 1,7 donc ça
ne fonctionne pas cependant je pense
qu'après cac et prend 1,5
bon les pions sont bien placés alors
elle a pas pris à la feda me3 elle a pas
voulu placer la structure donné le fort
en forçant trop noir et leur redonner de
l'espace et elle fait d'aveux trois cas
et qui vient en c4 prise leur re dame
français 4 et maintenance et puis on a
eu quatre qui est sous pression donc
ouverture plutôt réussie pour les noirs
même si bon les blancs sont pas ça va
c'est pas c'est pas c'est parce pas la
crise mais bon pas l'air d'avoir obtenu
grand chose pour le moment plus vanina
qui est assez mal autant elle lui reste
plus que une minute vingt ans avec avait
pas très bien autant on se rappelle
qu'elle n'était pas très habituel et pas
très habitué à jouer sur internet
irina crash non plus d'ailleurs
j'imagine parce que leurs lots est assez
assez assez famélique par rapport à leur
niveau
ces choses qu'on attendrait plutôt à 26
50 27 la surchasse comme ça ça dénote
quand même pratique pas très assidu du
jeu sur internet et vanilla qui envoient
eux cinq alors au cinq elle c'est hyper
tactique ou pas d'ailleurs
non c'est pas super tactique surprise
elle veut juste reprendre peut-être de
la dame ou peut-être plutôt du cavalier
parce que si elle reprend de la dame
j'imagine pour y voir du foot pro f3
d'un petit intermédiaires qui peut être
chiant parce que la dame et attaquer
maintenant et dans un français 5 france
et 5 c la tour qui attaque et donc pions
prend elle reprendrait du cavale et la
tour des quatre cavaliers cinq sont un
peu ndindy un nom parle en anglais fait
très attention sont un peu un peu un peu
un peu
comme ça bizarre mais bon il semble rien
et avoir pour les noirs à première vue
le tour va arriver en d1 et les blancs
qui vont s'organiser mais ça ça tiens ça
tiens ça tient à pas grand chose donc
prise de me prendre à lui que ça perdait
ça tour des huit donc le coup de plus
logique et on vient contester l'accolade
donc à la paire de fou pour les noirs
autour des 1 mais tour des huit logique
mais finalement ça crée pas de menace là
les blés blanc menace quand même tout
reprend des 8es dévier le fouet de
gagner la dame donc ses prix une fois et
la tour des huit impossible maintenant
autour des 8 est maintenant impossible
et on nous demandait ce que vanina et
bien française non elle est russe à
l'est pas du tout français n'a aucun
rapport donc donc donc tour des huit
pages web mais peut-être tour ses 8 ans
finalement logique mais valentina qui
s'en est pas mal tiré finalement est à
noter qu'il doit pas y avoir de problème
avec fou prend prises et cavaliers t7
qui pourrait être une idée parce qu'on
peut prendre juste en d4 et ça comme
dirait mur parce c'est ça va ya pas de
y'a pas de soucis pour les noirs ça
gagne du matériel donc les blancs qui
ont pas vraiment de menaces mais les
noirs qui peuvent pas faire le tour des
huit alors peut-être un coup comme ok
j'ai dit rachid qui a aidé 5 alors sa
rage ou du bordel au bordel là faut
calculer un cavalier prend des 5
j'imagine fou pranger 5e on va mettre la
variante dame prend g5 dame prend des
quatre cavaliers f6 échec roi ici ça je
sais pas je n'aurais pas eu confiance de
partir la dent avec les danses que les
cavaliers me font peur mais après va
savoir message aurait pas eu confiance
donc et prend des 5 auquel peut aussi
faire ok fou prend des cinq je pense
assez fou pranger 5 quand même dame
prend g5 et du coup reprendre bêtement
des 5 mai y aura peut-être du tour g4
auquel reprend des cinq direct du coin
qui a du coup pris ici prise ici et il
n'y a pas de vrai on peut pas utiliser
tout jeune mais tour g4 donc qu'ils
aient joué un coup donc on imagine est
possible dans une autre variante mais ça
doit pas être très grave y'a pas de
menace fondamentale pour les unes contre
les noirs damev 6
j'imagine bien joué qu'à et 17 hippies 6
chez pas au quai d'alger 3 ok là
j'imagine bien partir plus qu'à valider
cette mais j'ai pas trouvé l ul valve
affaire qui avait 17 ans maintenant elle
peut plus donc tour des huit alors
comment continue il ne reste plus que 15
secondes pour les blancs rouages de fou
bessette donc ça joue des petits coups
des petits coups dames 3 peut viser ici
peu visage s'il peut viser b6 la tour
qui viande et 5 qui s'activent
le cavaly cas probablement partir non
elle joue avec 4 ailes toujours agressif
un vanina valentina toujours agressif
tour g3 la tour qui revient libère du
cavalier gkd dames 5
voilà ça va ça va aller là mon avis les
blancs longueuil ajout l'annoncent
victoire des blancs d'alger six dames b1
quand même attention mais la dame
yvan e55 sûr d'un point et kelly prend
1,6
ouais voilà d'apcher cinq épreuves 6le
cheapos à sa santé qu'elle allait gagner
c'était le cheapos c'était qu'elle prend
ainsi sur tous les coups on a senti que
irina placer ses pièces il y avait il y
avait une difficulté emplacement pièces
pour irina ça se sentait et c'est la
défaite adha c'est la défaite à da pour
irin accroche donc qu'est ce qu'elle
nous joue avec les banques classiques y
sera aussi ce donc que trois sur un
genre deux trois poisons qui qui retombe
qui retombe dans une ouest indienne et
qui transpose aussi dans un genre de
système colle les noirs qui contrôle
bien la case la case e4 ici est une
position somme toute complètement
corrects pour les noirs webster qui
demandait ce que c'est le deuxième match
non c'est le troisième dans le premier
match danielian a éliminé à la surprise
générale
katerina l'agglo qui était tête de série
numéro 1 et dans le deuxième match
d'hier
alexandra kosteniuk qui a éliminé ana
zaton spire et donc la joueuse russe
s'est qualifié face à l'américaine et
aujourd'hui c'est un deuxième match
un deuxième match russie usa qui
pourrait qui pourrait être remporter une
nouvelle fois par une joueuse russe en
tout cas elle est allée favorite
valentina et le dernier match de ces
quarts de finale se jouera jeudi à 18h
et verra mari se bagarrent affronter
arica donc ce sera un match france-
france inde
alors fouet f5 food et 6
donc les blancs qui peuvent jouer à tout
moment contre un pion pendant un pur
isolé en prenant ses 5 et s'ouvrir le
fou mais après leur position sera pas
forcément avantageuses lecavalier 17
jaillir et vert vers 4 et les noirs
qu'une certaine activité allait le roi
qualifions mon prono pour ce match
à mon avis victoire de gouina sans
sourciller reprend rapidement d'un bon
livre pour pour attaquer fire en déborde
de dechy rohff alexei shirov au caire
hésitation alors est ce que pour prendre
de la dame elle a peur de quoi la peur
de cavaliers 5
ouais ça peut être pénible dans le sens
où si on prend prise bon quoique kg 4
semble sans doute possible c'est pas non
plus c'est pas non plus qu attaque at a
déjà perdu cavaliers à quatre peut-être
cavaliers à 4m sur 5m a lieu cinq ans
première vue mais cavaliers à 4 aussi
été possible parce que ça attaquait pas
mal de choses et ça aurait un vrai
cavalier à 4 était plus fort et français
c'est un we will survive exactement et
sur fou sur feu prend dans prend
cavaliers à 4 est un problème je pense
et cavaliers ou 5 comprend premier qui
avait un problème sur le pion des cinq
ans fait cavalier à 4 un peu pénible
c'est vrai que ce pion est pas simple à
défendre parce que sa menace aussi
celui-là
bien vu dans le chatt cavaliers ou 4 et
un problème qu'elle prenait 5 c'est pour
ça qu'elle a repris du cavalier prise et
qu'elle prend mais je suis jamais
convaincu du fait de me séparer
j'ai pas du tout aimé fou prend 17 et
puis en français 5 1 est-ce que je suis
le seul ce soir pour commenter way jeudi
aura fabien et vendredi maxime vachier
lagrave commente avec moi mais ce soir
je serai seul cavalier de
donc elle va réussir à planter un
cavalier en d4 et peut-être visé la
caserne
5 non mais c'est pas idiot tour 8 c'est
pas idiot c'est loin d'être idiot même
mes escales 4 des cas tu peux mettre la
dame dessus j'étais en train de me
demander d'amener des quatre cavaliers
aussi c'est ce qu'a vraiment une plus
value à ça avec un va lui aussi son va
mettre la dame angers 4 cavaliers si ce
n'est en fait fit mieux jouer défend et
maintenant tu as du caïd j'ai trois
cavaliers f5 vont tourner en premier
pourquoi paris lequel peut même venir en
f4 plutôt comme ça il visera et le pion
et on aura les idées peut-être de
cavalia h5 pour s'en prendre aux pions
g7 qui peut être intéressant à mon avis
l'aller les blancs sont beaucoup mieux
fou prend 17 pions prend finalement
c'était bien joué
finalement c'était très bien joué de la
part d'irina crush tour d un don qu'elle
s'en prend elle vit elle vise bien ce
pion et c'est difficile de le pousser ça
paraît impossible il ya une deux trois
quatre cinq pièces blanches qui contrôle
la case et 4 donc ça paraît impossible
donc il va falloir vivre avec le pion
d'amd 6 donc qu'elle prépare tour à des
huit ans tout bêtement là ça va pas plus
loin et il n'y a pas de mauvais de
mauvais clouage pour le moment la tour
qui arrive en des 8 et la sueur
cavaliers h5 j'imagine qu'elle veut
jouer dame g6 du coup ça lui permet de
couvrir le pion g7 avec la dame et du
coup de chasser les blancs alors comment
est ce que les blancs vont progresser
maintenant h3 c'est vrai qu'avec les
noirs la question c'est qu'est-ce que tu
joues est-ce que tu joue cavalier e 6
peut-être points peut échanger des
pièces elle vend aux quatre ce qui doit
en soit être pas à mauvais et elle est
ok donc là en fait c'est un peu un peu
marrant parce que les blancs ils ont ils
ont vu ils viennent de mettre quelques
coups offensifs consécutif mais mais du
coup là il ya un petit à petit il ya un
petit moment de blocage adam qui parent
h6 et maintenant il ya une idée c'est de
faire pousser 5 et peut-être même fou
ces cinq suivis de cavaliers pros f2 est
fou prend 1,3 je me demande si ça marche
juste fou ces cinq là avec les noirs il
ya ça qui est en prise mais fou c'est ça
que c'est quand même une option puisque
où va la dame après on peut quand même
enchaîné
on peut imaginer un truc comme ça va je
sens quand même c'est une gueule d'un
truc qui va pas fonctionner mais on
pourrait partir dans un truc comme ça il
ya ça emprise aussi ouais je sais pas
peut-être ça peut marcher 1
je vais jeter un oeil aujourd'hui parce
que ça pouvait être jolie si ça marchait
ces cinq leurs dix années quoi adam
pranger cet échec
dimpre emprise prise tout reprend 17
maintenant et sur cavaliers pros f2 à ce
moment là on peut juste prendre et
surtout prend 1,3 du coup on a ragé 3
donc on est fou c'est 5 qui fonctionnait
pas à cause de dames pranger cette jolie
défense mais maintenant après tour c'est
infuser 5 qui fonctionne bien évidemment
bon là c'est cadeau de la part de dire
in a craché la cac et prend f2 boom
paraissait complètement finir étonnant
étonnant d'avoir laissé pousser 5
c'était l'idée des noirs ça devrait
quand même gros comme une maison
étonnant d'avoir laissé cette cette
combinaison ouvrir quant à elle fait
tourner cette année mais pas du tout
calculer les dames pranger 7 et
compagnie et donc elle se le prend
maintenant
c'était pas une combine impressionnante
il faut prendre dit adam bref alors
est-ce qu'on fait dame prend à adam
premiers quatre français 5 attention non
il faut faire oui à tout reprendre 3
aussi jouable en somme s'il faut prendre
trois ans nous demander si les leçons de
chasse points comme valent le coup et ça
vaut le coup noc
je sais pas quand est-ce que ça va être
mis en français ça prend un peu plus de
temps que prévu j'ai l'impression mais à
mai mais ça va ça va y arriver pour le
monde tout cas si tu parle anglais c'est
vraiment bien donc d'en prendre trois
faut prendre trois prises et maintenant
peut-être des quatre donc qu'elles sont
cette fronde 3 fallait faire je sais pas
des quatre échecs intermédiaire ok donc
ça c'est assez logique
ok oui le truc c'est que sur cavaliers
prend maintenant il ya toujours eu huit
échecs et surtout prend le truc c'est
que fou prend f3 ok j'ai cinq nageuses 5
c'est bien joué elle s'en prend à ça
peut-être il faut essayer de haine
entoure ces 8 tu comprends f4 c'est sûr
échec ouais ok je pense que c'est la
bonne idée avec avec les blancs
d'essayer jouer sur ce roi un peu faible
parce que surtout france et 8 en france
et 8 ça va mater fins à sagan la dame
donc dame ait fuité là il faut espérer
qu'ils aient quelque chose
les meilleures prises prison peut jamais
on jamais contrôler la case ses huit
puisque c'est une case sur noir sur
blanc pardon et qu'on a le fou de cases
noires et là il va juste faire [ __ ] en
f3 et dame prend des quatre voilà c'est
chose faite
vanina qui marque le deuxième point
vanina qui s'envole déjà dans ce match
elle est favorite
et on voit qu'en tactique la différence
de niveau est quand même assez
impressionnante
parce que vanina est vraiment parti à
l'as fait cavalier qu'intel s'est
construite truqué son adversaire a pas
du tout du tout du tout une idée de quel
point m 2 qui est pourtant très
thématiques
bon ok pour le mans vanina domine donc
maintenant on a un gambit dame accepter
une variante france est vrai à 6b 5-fu
de aussi ça va jouer ces cinq ans d'un
coup ça ressemble un petit peu à des
mets rend ses positions là dans la slab
ceux des positions qui sont semi cela
pardon c'est des positions qui sont plus
ou moins équilibrés savas quand les
noirs vont jouer c'est ça qu'on va un
moment donné à voir un truc un peu un
peu symétrique en réalité parce que les
pions à les pions cd pourrait s'échanger
et du coup les les pions seront les uns
en face des autres
les blancs qui vont peut-être échangés
en c5 un moment donné mais l'a surpris
en français 5 ceci si les noirs de fer
fou prend des six qui est des six ans
serait très content mais les noirs qui
vont évidemment reprendre du cavalier et
sur damas quatre y aurait au pire
d'amener cette ya pas il n'y a pas de
problème lorsqu'on demande quand est-ce
que je vais organiser mon sutto je sais
pas albator plus tard c'est pas
important programme ans et passent pas
la question de stream là c'est pas la
question de ces c'est pas le bon stream
pour parler de ça du coup b3 foulée deux
cavaliers des cinq donc ouais le four b2
qui est bien placé puisqu'il vise la
grande diagonale mais après quand on
joue b3 le problème c'est que le pion
des idées font plus la casse ces 3es et
noir qui vont venir éventuellement se
placer sur cette case
cavalia six cavaliers ou quatre qui
serait une idée est donc la dame ans ces
deux traits qu'elle est pas mal placé
par rapport à ça alors est-ce que tour
c'est 8 puis on prend et pour ses 8
semble faire sans ce niveau car ici le
match s'arrête si un retard
irrattrapable où ça joue jusqu'au bout
il ya un enjeu financier par exemple
pour la suite de la partie la victoire
est déjà acquise
alors il ya un petit enjeu financier ou
pourcentage de victoires mais off c'est
on parle de 50 ou 100 dollars ce qui est
très peu pour pour des joueurs de ce
calibre il gagne même même des joueuses
de sivola gagnent très bien leur vie
donc elles ne sont pas à 100 dollars
près très clairement et moi je dirais
malheureusement le match
le match continue continu continu
continu continu et s'arrête jamais ce
qui est un poil dommages en fait quand
il ya des matches très déséquilibré il
pourrait y avoir un point de genre à +10
par exemple donc cette position très
intéressante harry 6 km à 9,7 j'aime
bien le ku'damm 7 parce que la dame elle
est sur une colonne fermé et les blancs
qui vont avoir un souci avec ces dames
ces deux parce qu'elle est mal placé
pour le moment le cavalier c4 est cloué
et c'est vrai qu'elle serait mieux à eux
deux mais en e2 jeu c'est pas un truc
qui va pas donc elle fait que quatre
avec le fouet donc elle fait eu quatre
avec l'idée ce qu'elle va réussir à
jouer cinq peut-être alain peut-être
qu'un coup comme cavani c3 est
envisageable
à voir est-ce que ont réussi à attaquer
assez fortement le pion e4 après
twickenham français 3 et pas jouable et
le pion aux quatre peu un peu être
ciblés et à la fait à l'afrique est
restée trois escales à jouer c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que les blancs sont
pas très bien organisé il ya ça qui
traîne un peu il ya ça qui traîne un peu
si lecavalier c4 bouge le pion c3 va
être bien placé et les noms un peu vu
tout vouloir jouer cavalier e 5
mais bon à voir là c'est concret
peut-être un coup comme cavalier de haut
et fort qui s'est acquis des jouets qui
prend ses 3 mai camaïeu deux peut-être
juste dame
d'un des quatre tours à quatre mois
c'est difficile c'est difficile comme
position il ya vraiment beaucoup de
choses pas encore que sur cavalier e 2
on pourra toujours faire cavalier ces
accueils c5 peut être 5 mais en fait je
n'ai repris sur kelly citron pour se
refaire faut prendre un prof ou prend
donc en réalité cavaliers deux menaces
pas forcément grand chose donc cavalier
e 2 et touré sur dame bkc tout reprend
17 donc cavalier deux peut-être tour des
huit vêtements
c'est le coup de la partita du coup tour
des huit
peut-être bêtement autour des 8 parce
que cavalier ces cinq cavaliers 5e 5
c'est peut-être un peu pénible ça bloque
le fou est peut-être le fouet perdu
d'air au delà de ça peut-être un mais
dans tous les cas on n'a pas envie à mon
avis de partir là dedans encore serait
pas finir et peut-être camaïeu carte
avec les de faire dame c5 ou cavaliers
prend b3 avec l'idée dame ces cinq
échecs
ok enfin en réalité wef inquiet c'est 5e
saint cloud g5 ok ils sont pas obligés
de faire f 4 ils peuvent simplement
encaissé le pion on peut faire tour des
huit ans bêtement key ces trois pouces
et 3 fou prend un quart à trets et ça va
aller au café cavalier e cinq cavaliers
cinq cavaliers 5 pourquoi est-ce que ça
me plaisait - alors y avait aussi carlit
décision j'ai pas parlé que j'avais pas
vu elle a pris ici pris ici pris ici
mais là elle va prendre ses trois et
prendre quatre noms ou c'est moi qui dit
vas y vas y aura égalité matérielle mais
il ya peut-être dame b4 aussi qui est un
coup
dans des cafés peut-être un coup puisque
savez la pression sur les cavaliers
alors pour ac 1 aidé à me prends à 5
peut-être un c'est ça l'idée surtout
racea elle veut prendre à 5
elle veut prendre à 5 et garder la paire
de fou et garder un petit avantage comme
la perte de fous ici dans la position
ouverte et le pion aux six est plus
avantageuse et plus est s'ils sont bien
placés pour bloquer le fou 10 tours
d'essai ainsi non m et tours d'essai un
tu gardes ta tour mal voilà tu gardes le
clouage mais bon tour d'essai un
peut-être un peu tête il faut c'est ce
qu'elle joue d'ailleurs et peut-être
vous prend ses 3 est quand même obligé
mais quand on prend 1,4 oui bon on va
pas perdre on va pas perdre raciste
parce qu'il y aura un clouage sur la
colonne s'est bien évidemment mais c'est
vrai qu'on sera un peu moins bien si on
fait ça et quand dans cette finale en
fait les blancs sont mieux pourquoi
parce que le pion à six il est un peu en
en ligne de mire tu as peut être un peu
ça peut ça peut être un problème ça donc
elle a fait tous rêvent d imiter
maintenant j'imagine tour à 4 à mes
tours à 4 elle peut pas parce que moment
il ya alp où elle peut pas tour à quatre
dames france et 3 prises ces trois prix
ces trois prises ces trois tours d un
échec fouet fin tout reprend ses trois
pas possible donc tout va des huit
interdit tour à 4h 3 c'est pour ça
qu'elle le joug elle se garde le droit
h2 et maintenant est ce que les noirs
[Musique]
n'ont intérêt à prendre puisque après
sinon il y aurait eu tour à 4 l aurais
pas pu le faire
en ce sens elle doit prendre en c3 a
tourné un échec intermédiaire assez joli
elle est forte cette vanina le fameux
tour d'un échec j'avais pas vu non plus
est un grand classique un grand
classique
un grand classique mais mon époux f1 il
ya tout reprend ses 3 ouais c'est du
grand classique ça à tête
normalement tu
patate le prendra mais c'est vanina qui
se prends je te couleurs inversées
semenya qui allie blanc pourquoi j'ai
l'impression que cala et les noirs rixe
qu'il y avait la tactique en fait du
coup je me suis renversée dans les
changements de couleurs parce qu'il ya l
échiquier tourne pas donc elle s'est
pris tour d un ac c'est bête de se
prendre ça c'est vrai qu'elle était un
peu sous pression et tour c'est un tour
des huit c'était bien joué 1
il y avait cette menace qui rôde et
c'était pas si facile à voir donc c'est
irina brook et qui revient au score
serena qui revient au score à 2-1 et qui
recolle avec ce joli thème tactique du
tour d'un échec grands classiques et
c'est vrai que qu'on pouvait avoir
l'impression de ça arrive ce genre de
tactique parce qu'en fait tour à 4
c'était l'idée des blancs
juste pour revenir un peu de manière
rétrospective j'espère que vous aux
dames b3 incroyable missclick incroyable
elle pensait qu'elle allait faire date
dame cavalli c6 peut-être hall alors
donné une partie comme ça c'est cadeau à
le cadeau le cadeau le missclick assez
dommage de reperdre tous les efforts sur
sur une dame mal placé là comme ça aïe
aïe aïe ridicule la nina qui sourd sipa
vanina qui assure le même visage
ah mais ça c'est dommage a le cadeau
par contre pas très fair de prendre la
wind comme ça non ou c'est normal du
mans de police est là qu est ce que tu
veux faire en fait ses gammes sais pas
si tu joues tu joue au tennis à l'ail à
roland garros il ya une balle let tu
prends le point qu'est ce que tu dois
faire en fait t'as la balle qui touche
le fils elle retombe dans du côté
adverse avons basse et gagner c'est
gagner enfin ati peut rien citic tu peux
y faire mais c'est vrai que vanina ses
rangs pokerface a donc revu un nouveau
grand vide à m'accepter va sortir la
théorie sorcière l'ouverture d'un
caillou 7 qui est pas mal placé dans le
sens où il pourra remplacer le cavalier
ces six l'arrêt ce qui permet un csc tu
petit peu rien tu vas pas te mettre en
scène c'est en échangeant là c'est ça en
fait c'est que ce que tu veux faire en
fait qu'est ce que tu peux faire
tu peux pas faire grand chose
après ses classes de redonner la partie
mais bon on peut pas on peut pas
critiquer vanina là dessus hein c'est
pas response portif de prendre la dame
peut-être en plus on sait même pas que
c'est un mix clic ou si c'était un nom
ça devait être un mystique quand même et
juste à la jouer tellement vite
comme c'est un prêt move bon français
trois fiancées 3 se sépare de la perte
de fou mais parce qu'elle veut jouer un
peu la structure
ces 500 prend aux cavaliers alors il ya
deux options etc et b5 et f3 mais kébé 5
c'est intéressant parce qu'elle peut
partir éventuellement vers des 6 es là
tu peut même avoir des idées de faire du
tourp rendu fou est caduc fc sète mais
je pense que le cavalier peut venir
juste angers 6 au pire et ça va aller
mais juste votre faut toujours regarder
quand vous pouvez vous en prendre à 7
tours rebondir avec le cavalier faut
toujours jeter un oeil parce que ça peut
ça peut rapporter des choses ça peut
rapporter
mais la prise cavaliers ses sept tours b
vite marche pas trop bien fait juste h3
bon alors ça fait pas grand chose mais
ça ça pose une question noire comment tu
continues tu prépares peut-être f4f 3e 5
trucs comme ça qui peut être pas qui va
être fort en fait ce que tu veux avancer
la majorité et en mettant deux pions aux
cinq ans plus gagnera cette app ios 5 la
casse des six pour le cavale qui est
déjà semi gagner là les noirs ont une
grosse question puisque surtout bessette
pour probablement qui a aidé si c'est
pénible sera obligé de reboucher le fou
en c6 qui sera pas forcément bien placé
tu vas te prendre f4 le cavaly qui
défend bien le cavaly qui va de repartir
il aurait aimé repartir en c6 mais du
coup il peut pas et je sais pas moi les
blancs peuvent continuer l'embarras du
choix mais même un coup juste comme
fouet f3 et c'est assez sympathique à
jouer
donc h3 ça pose une question aux noirs
en fait comment qu'est-ce que tu joues
que fais-tu fois aussi ce bon du coup
ses coups que j'allais vous proposer
mais maintenant f4f quatre à le faire
caler ses 4 il n'y a pas le temps de f5
pascal praud de 3 dont cavaliers des six
très logique gagne la case c4 et sur
dame c'est cette f4 tour des huitièmes
puis on prend 1,5 qui défend le cavalier
des six donc qu'à valider s'il n'y a pas
le temps de jouer ce clouage les blancs
réussissent à se défendre mais c'est
vrai qu'avec 4 sera sera un coup assez
assez assez assez pénible quand même pas
ce campus afpa tu pour enchaîner
peut-être mais malkav saint caprais et
f6 c'est un plan assez classique ça f4
f5 m6 dans ses positions en plus ça sur
chaque coup tu menaces une pièce sur la
colonne est adjacente
donc c'est intéressant on va voir
on va voir
cavale et ses huit cars et les f-5 ok
elle recule donc haïssent ils étaient
pourchassés cavaliers 5
est ce que ça peut être intéressant de
faire échange massif
la paire de fou est vraiment forte ici
les pièces noires sont très mal organisé
donc elle n'a pas pris à l'afev ou c4
pressée 4-1 hockey prend l'an dernier
pas le temps il faut prendre cette
reprise cktr j'imagine dame g4 va
arriver c'est complètement dans le style
de vanina menace maths et sur damas fils
peut-être fouache 6 menace d'un projet
cet échec comme ça il n'y a pas le temps
de il n'y a pas le temps de cavaliers 5
adam prend g7 est sûre j'ai six chats
fou prend et cuites çà semble ça semble
dur parce que là toutes les pièces
blanches ont convergé sur le roi et le
roi noir qui étaient les pièces noires
sont mal placés un vêtement sait pas à
qui avait germé sont même que j'ai 6
pour le mans c'est le meilleur coup que
je vois il ya peut-être plus fort mais
je vois je vois rien de mieux que j'ai 6
à peut-être d'alger six dames g6 fou
pranger cette tour bouge et continuer la
partie comme ça alphée g6 peut-être
d'injustice parce que cavalli hossa qui
avait rien il y avait cavaliers prends
je vais juste regarder alors dix petites
secondes et je pense que dame justice
permettez de dams cisco numéro un hu est
sa part s était à plus deux mais ça
permettait de semis rester dans la
partie encore parce que là il ya qualité
de plus dans une position complètement
écrasante pour les blancs on n'a pas
trouvé d'armes g6 et ça risque de faire
4-1
on va voir mes cavaliers pros en trois
doit faire ffe et la colonne ne va
s'ouvrir colonel va s'ouvrir pardon et
ça me parait catastrophique earle haley
celle de ramasser les pions dame f4
menace ma tendance qui est toujours
agréable quand même et maintenant autour
des 1 tour 17 tours 8 et peut-être juste
on prend à s'être déjà pour ramasser un
peu
à moins que vanina trouve mieux elle
fait dam des six alors qu'est-ce qu'elle
menaçait mla ce sein que si ces menaces
ces menaces elles menacent 5e 6 ces
trois pas de gain pour le moment pour
les blancs férois ge de son unité sur
dame prend 1,3 secure adam f 6 ouais
menace mathy si ça a l'air quand même de
finir le boulot damev 6 1 il n'y a pas
d'échec est sûre dam des quatre dames
prend et c'est gagné
eh ben ça fait quatre ans les amis ça
fait 4 1 et le scénario du match qui
semble vraiment en faveur de vanina qui
est la fille la jouer ce qui nous donne
la plus grande impression pour le monde
en ce speech s alors qu'est-ce qu'il est
sage quelques messages à des bonnes
femmes on a déjà parlé hier les mecs on
va pas on va pas faire des débats
redondant il se trouve qu'au échec les
hommes jouent mieux c'est pour ça qu'il
ya une catégorie hommes et catégorie
femmes farine catégorie mx une catégorie
femme est ce que si c'était que mixa
élèves et les vrais le dès le niveau des
femmes qui égalerait les hommes on n'en
sait rien donc j'ai envie de dire déjà
parlé maintes et maintes fois le débat
le débat et semi clos donc oui on a une
nouvelle fois je veux un parti où est
prévu un jour il ya vu le sait hier une
partie avait le g6 un peu tôt il y avait
un truc à 4 4 mais il y avait eu le
cavalier a eu de la part de kosteniuk
alors fou des six
c'est peut-être cavalier e 5 et une
option ici faut cinq à six pattes une
option ont fait 5 bizarre peut-être cac
valeo 5 donc 45 peut être une option
mais une accroche qui doit qui doit
faire quelque chose maintenant elle doit
revenir au score il ya trois points de
trois points de différence
on en est où dans le match il ya déjà 40
48 de jeu moi ce qui m'impressionne
toujours avec les matchs d'échec j'ai
pas si vous avez vous fait pareil mais
là ça fait quarante minutes qu'on
regarde le match j'ai l'impression qui
s'est écoulé une dizaine de minutes
on va dire 15 20 minutes maximum je
trouve que ça passe à une vitesse
incroyable
je sais pas pour vous mais moi c'est
match de trois heures trente
en tout cas la première heure et demie
passe passe assez vite après en revanche
quand il n'ya plus le camp ya plus
suspense advient longuet est très vite
en fait tu peux on va dire franchement
tu peux te faire chier c'est là par
exemple si elle arrive à +7 plus suite à
la fin du 5 + 1 tu vois les la dernière
heure et demie de jeu va être un peu
longue tu as c'est un peu longuet
en revanche tant que les matches sont
serrés et où je trouve que c'est
vraiment passionnant à suivre ça
enchaîne les parties s'enchaînent les
plans s'enchaînent et c'est intéressant
alors ici j'avais vraiment bien les
blancs
j'ai l'impression que les attaques des
blancs est plus facile à mener néon
j'ai l'habitude d'être côté noir en fait
avec ces trucs là mais avec vanina va
faire ses 5 mai ses doigts la colonne
s'est alors comment est ce que les
blancs doivent doivent se démerder
est ce qu'on fait f3 tu peux pas ok j'ai
cinq voyages 5 ça me paraît être plus ou
moins forcé parce que tu veux pas
laisser h 4 h 5 pour monter et
maintenant qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
comment est-ce que tu ouvres le truc
avec les blancs et tu peux faire un
petit coup droit bien si tu as envie
c'est simple tu pourras prendrais tu
peux la jouer stratégie contre le pion
des ça peut être une option de pas
forcément jouer droit de dire que tu as
réussi à mobiliser une pièce noire et
que tu joues maintenant la supériorité
numérique
et puis on prend c'est ce qu'elle fait
qu'ils aient cada y est par contre sheth
com/fr je me connais que très peu aux
échecs mais je te sens passionnés
impliqué tu me donne envie de regarder
des matchs plus souvent eh ben merci à
toi merci à toi donc elle est partie en
un avec le roi donc elle veut éviter
aussi les fouets f5
bon maintenant il faut quand même que
les blancs le truc c'est qu'on s'est mis
sur le reculoir côté blanc et vu qu'on
s'est mis sur le reculoir
on a du mal à avancer à faire des coups
offensifs parce que là du coup ça joue
un peu trop sur ce carré d'échiquier à
mon goût et les blancs ont du mal à laon
du mal à s'en sortir
l'avocat est ce qu'il y ait un peu de ce
qui se passerait si on était meilleurs
joueurs du monde contre alpha 0 bas il
ferait défoncé alors avoir les blancs et
ça donne un avantage parce que tu donne
le ton de la partie mais c'est pas non
plus énorme énorme donc town d2 c'est
logique car elle vise epyon dessin non
qu'elle met un peu le plan dont on avait
parlé en place c'est-à-dire de la jouer
stratégique deuxième va pas attaquer le
roy on se dit que le cavalier h5 c'est
une pièce qui joue pas donc on a une
pièce de plus que si ça s'échange ben du
coup le avantage numérique va de plus en
plus se voir et que les noirs pourront
pas mener d'attaqués parce qu'ils ont
simplement moins de pièces et souvent en
échec il faut vraiment toutes ces pièces
pour attaquer donc c'est un peu de faire
c'est un peu le pari de un peu le pari
de
d'irina avec les blancs ici c'est de te
dire voilà j'ai une pièce de plus fait
ton attaque
elle passera pas et puis moi petit à
petit je vais m'organiser alors vanina
elle s'en fout complètement ça ne
l'intéresse pas elle lui envoie les
pions dans la gueule c'est à dire que l
en fait elle a un objectif je crois
c'est mettre le pion à a3 et de
commencer à jouer sur les cases noires
donc là clairement et le plan des noirs
c'est à 4 à 3 et puis après de faire
dame cinq tours c8 et puis de te dire ok
mon lecavalier parents je m'en fait je
m'en fous certes elle ça ne l'intéresse
pas et si jamais tu fais tu fais un truc
un jour peut-être il revient en jeu il
te tue donc le cavalier en d4 il va
quand même colmater la diagonale maroci
qui a raison qui a tort est ce que les
scolaires est quelqu'un qui a raison
quelqu'un qui a tort on ne sait pas
alors peut-être que la position jouer et
d'apprendre des cards un premier quinté
tour c'est un échec donc ce n'était pas
jouable pour ses huîtres on apprend des
cas toujours pas jouable et surtout
reprend elle va refaire tout reprend
j'imagine quoique dame prend aussi aussi
aux six candidats mais c'est vrai que ce
mec-là du mal à revenir en jeu et ça
peut être un problème à terme pascal 6
ça paraît jamais possible avoue pranger
si c'est même ça paraît long et donc
elle fait h41 ne veut pas perdre le pion
ça ça peut se comprendre et sur a3 le
juste faire b 3 mai à peut-être la case
c3 qui va s'offrir au noir mais qu'elle
va faire à 3
on imagine quand même b3 même si on
n'est pas obligé de toucher à quoi que
ce soit est ce que ça marche vraiment
cette attaque
on va voir
elle prend à trois prises aussi possible
1re pions prend à trois elles se gardent
la casse b3 pour le cavalier du coup et
elle donne pas la case ces trois-là tour
a presque tour c3t vraiment un coup
puisque avec arrêt lieu de ça c'est un
autre débat donc prise une maligne du
coup on reprend avec la dame pour les
noirs
et attention maintenant parce que dès
que ddd qu'on va pouvoir rentrer sur
cette diagonale
ça va être mat mais d'un autre côté il
n'y a pas de raison qu'on puisse rentrer
sur cette diagonale avec les noirs
cependant comment comment on joue avec
les blancs est ce qu on fait un coup de
tourbe et un non j'ai pas encore quelle
est l'idée tour b 1 mais peut-être dame
b 4 pour échanger les dames tête pour
bert dame b 4 elle fait cavalier p3l
veut faire tour c'est un ouais c'est
peut-être même mieux même probablement
c'est vrai que les changes des dames va
pas forcément favorisé les noirs qui
vont toujours resté que ce qui a valu au
bord cavaliers au bord pas fort c'est
une petite expression c'est un petit
dicton échiquier un dicton de rien du
tout donc ça et chaque et dames h2o
assez bien pensé ça d'ailleurs il y
avait aussi dans les coups intéressants
possible y avait peut-être dû tout
reprendre à me prend et cavaliers f4 qui
était aussi une option avec l'idée qu'on
attaque le fou et qu'on veut revenir en
russie ce ce qui paraît à ce qui
paraissait assez fort mais peut-être
dame prend à trois là dessus et la
partie continuer mais cette idée qui
rôdait de remettre un cavalier en f4
possible mais damas jeu c'est
intéressant parce qu'elle vient prendre
un peu les blancs à contre-pied et elle
veut sans parce qu'en fait si elle gagne
h4 et g5 le cavalière vient en jeu et
c'est bien et d'un autre côté elle a
aussi dû dames c'est un qui rôdent alors
dame g1 qui rôdent échecs dames c3 alors
elle s'en prend aux pions à trois c'est
plutôt intéressant et sur dame géant
elle va faire flou b1
fou sera un peu moche mais c'est pas
grave alors une possibilité ce serait de
continuer peut-être par dame j'ai un fou
d'alger un fourbe et un fouet f5
cavaliers prend puis on prend mais là ya
peut-être des dames ses huit dames prend
f5 qui sont pénibles à voir voire même
juste dame prend à 3 et c'est vrai que
là les blancs sont pas si mal tirée donc
elle fait fou g4 la dame qui prend elle
à jénine que les noirs doivent s'en
prendre aux pions blancs à vitesse grand
v
la dame qui vient colmater le pion aux 3
et qui menace d'un 8 échecs et on peut
peut-être faire dame prend h4 dame 8,3
bouche d'ann f7 aidé à me ranger 5 et on
colle matraquant la dame se rangeait 5
le pion g6 elle fait cavalier g3 donc
elle veut pas donner le plus bref cette
non plus elle veut ramener son cavalier
en jeu c'est vrai que c'est très bien
joué aussi
c'est plus offensif c'est mieux pensée
dames 8 et peut-être cavaliers c6 temps
elle fait d'un me 5
et c'est vrai qu'on arrive pas vraiment
attaqué ce roi noir qui reste solide
mais d'un autre côté les noirs
réussissent pas à attaquer le roi blanc
s est compliquée les amis c'est
difficile de tron c'est peut-être d'amd
de 1 kw assez piégeur avec qui des dames
pranger trois dames c'est un échec
roberdam ces trois matches bon ça doit
pas être super fort mesdames des deux
dents mais c'est vrai que ça menace le
fou en plus belle c'est intéressant
c'est un petit piège en plus avec peu de
temps sur la pendule pour l'adversaire
ça pourrait être intéressant mais elle
va faire quoi d'amener de ces vicieux
quand même la musique c'est très vicieux
est mal à faire ça et cavaliers afin
qu'ils aient aussi bien joué et
cavaliers pro 3 qui défend le fou tout
en attaquant de l'autre côté et
maintenant il ya jusqu'à valley ces
quatre échecs et dame prend un f4 et
ouais ça a craqué et ça fait plus 4 la
démonte ada est en route
irina crush qui est dans le rouge
il ya déjà plus 4 déjà +4 et c'est un
cavalier seul un elle domine autant à la
position qui est résident à noter bien
d'année c'est marrant ouais ça craque
côté côté irina mais si ça craque c'est
parce que ça joue bien côté valentina
valinakis au top et vanina qui domine ce
match vraiment de la tête et des épaules
on a du mal à voir contrairement même au
match d'hier où il y avait des secteurs
de jeu où on sentait que ça pouvait ça
pouvait tourner mais là en fait on voit
on voit pas on voit pas dans quel monde
ils rennais meilleur ici peut-être dam
des deux était jouable
non mais ça c'est bien je divague ouais
c'est vrai que ces dames français trois
foulées 2c c'est quand même risqué la
dame de france et trois pour pourquoi
venir prendre ce pion après peut-être
que ça existe mais bon elle se reprend
la foudre là ça va elle va prendre la
grêle là bas il à eelv a grêlé sur les
noirs là ça va pas du tout contre vanina
donné sa vanina mais moi j'aurais peur
la faim j'ai envie de dire mais moi
surtout moi la contrebande ina je suis
en sueur un puisqu'il faut faire h
si elle arrache 5 prendre prendre et
rauque et j'ai envie de dire
après il ya des suicides suicide squad
kouame mais bon j'ai pas très envie quoi
bah elle va faire ça mais mme émond
ouais ouais ouais ok tu vas te rendre
damage cinq tours eu enfin qu'est ce que
c'est que ça c'est à un pion plus pour
cette merde c'est pas cher payé un rien
après ça tient peut-être mais mais bon
on est ambitieux c'est quand même un peu
spécial h 6 non mais là c'est plus du
courage là c'est de la folie ça menace
rien h61 d'ailleurs on peut juste faire
tourer ainsi on a envie peut-être tour à
eux-mêmes pour jouer tour sept tours à 1
et sur cavaliers sait si c'est peut-être
du coup on prend h6 prises et tours 3 et
on va faire tout rejet 3 ramène à ce
niveau là c'est plus du courage ça c'est
de la folie tous cas déjà tour alain
minima et moi c'est un coût qui me
plairait pas ce que tu me l'as tour
cette fois prend 1,6 non mais là ça me
parait ça me paraît conclut le compliqué
là
tout commence à s'en va être le coût le
plus simple en fait vous prend à chis
bon avec les noms là faut prendre tempo
sarah de réfléchir de toute façon si tu
prends pas c'est matt aussi j'aurais pas
commencé par photographier j'aurais pas
senti de j'aurais pas eu envie de me
précipiter là dessus mais après ça gagne
peut-être en ligne elle a dû calculer de
toute façon elle calcule mieux que moi
y'a pas y'a pas grand nom mais là faut
prendre quand même un de toute façon tu
as pas de choix les cheveux un petit
coup d'ordi hockey l'idée c'est ghm
prend h6 f5 et tour a eu un donc c'est
le même plan mais dans cet ordre la
larme ok mais là tu as juste prendre
foucher simple retour à auquel veut
faire preuve saint amé fois f5 y aura
foule ou trois par un fou j'ai cinq fois
f5 fouet trois s'étaient encore fous
j'ai 6 mai à foug pranger 6 pas de
chance donc il ya encore pions prend ok
peut-être elle veut jouer ça mais bon
ces pions - et ses catastrophes c'est
une poubelle un live un café damage 4
ae sur flu f5 bouger ça me paraissait
plus logique hein mais ça doit aller
très bien
c'est vrai que ça fait ça fait mal à ce
début de match c'est on a un peu
abasourdis les amis irina et crush on la
voit plus du tout à l'écran elle fait
comme dans les speech est masculin quoi
comme comme les comme les adultes comme
les grands bref c'est pas le lapin
question d'adultes puisque elle a raté
ça j'imagine vanina a pris ce prix soit
f5 bon bah ninacs doigts qui doit être
gagnante encore mais je pense qu'elle a
raté que c'est cet ordre de coups là
j'ai l'habitude du truc junior
maintenant a commenté de millicom des
grands comme les adultes mais là comme
les comme le mix la marina qui disparaît
de l'écran petit à petit faire mieux
disparaître dans l'autre sens vers le
bas donc tour à tour trois qui va
arriver et tout rejet 3 ça va ça va ya
les caisses
va tenter ce qu'elle va tenter qu'il
sait si ce qui a valu au 5 mai qu'elle
sait si ce tour trois cavaliers ou 5
pour h3 et on ce que je voulais colmater
en fait la casse g6 avec lecavalier mais
du coup les blancs qui décalé qui
attaque sur h7n tour 3 et orge et troyes
et tours h3 du coup là et c'est matt je
vois pas comment on empêche d'un match 8
matt va la tenter cette défense elle n'a
pas dû voir il a dû calculer tour j'ai
trois cavaliers g6 l'a pas vu tour à
froid est là pas du tout âge 3 les amis
elle a raté ça elle a raté tous rage
froid et ses maths ça va faire 6 1 un
7-0 c'est roland garros les amis ouais
non le c'est clair que le speech est
junior est plus fort que le speech est
féminin ja oui à fuir ou déjà pour ne
citer qu'eux il ya sarah n'a ici tienko
la plupart des des joueurs dans le
speech à junior serait favori pour
gagner le speech est féminin on s'y sent
envahie n'est pas français de vanina
aime bien et francophile on va dire un
drapeau français
donc ça fait 6 1 ouais ok une petite
baisse de régime dans une partie et puis
sinon c'est un cavalier seul et c'est
vraiment le match le plus déséquilibré
de la saison parce qu'on voit on voit
vraiment pas je vais me répéter mais
dans les autres matches même qui était
un peu déséquilibré comme celui d'hier
par exemple de kosteniuk on se
raccrocher à quelque chose avait quand
même des positions il y avait quand même
du jeu là c'est là c'est juste un
massacre 1 alors qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
qui est derrière qui touche la lampe des
arts ina on se passe qui fait sens et
pas il est là mais on sait pas on sait
pas ce qu'il fait c'est quoi le projet
de la personne on ne sait pas
est-ce que causé nuke et favorite
demande daniel un bonne question daniel
je pense pas gomina à l'air quand même
d'être assez tranchantes on sait qu'elle
est forte en rapide a été championne du
monde après l'élimination de d'ekaterina
l'agglo on peut on peut penser que green
à la favorite
c'est dur à dire et merci à ril rox.kis
abonnés à la chaîne chaise comme et
faire avec tout type rail merci merci
tonton ça fait plaise
je te remercie au nom de chess comme
rideau dans tous les sens du terme
images hypnotiques et c'est là que les
matches qui sont comme comme on disait
qu'ils peuvent qui peuvent paraître un
peu longuet qui peut être un peu longue
et parce que parce que la domination est
clair alors cette partie là on n'a pas
encore trop parlé il ya le pion
vahina qui a accepté de se faire faire
des pions doublé contre la la paire de
fou mais je sais pas j'ai pas ça
m'inspire pas grand chose ce placement
thiès un peu un peu un peu bizarre après
c'est peut-être une prépa est ce qu'on
veut dire que c'est une domination des
15000 streamer demande aux deux qu'il
abat mais forcément moi ça me fait
plaisir de voir vanina dominer comme ça
peut-être tour serra pour irina pour
mettre un peu la pression sur la colonne
ces menaces et du cavalier prend du kgb
5 ou qui prend des cinq peut-être pas
idiot et bien sûr moi ça me fait très
plaisir un mec dit le match danielian
l'agglo est encore plus déséquilibré sur
le papier wayne on a vite senti que dan
ayant été forte en blitz on my way on a
vite senti ça alors que on a vite senti
que le match sera équilibré alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas vraiment le
sentiment que ça donne presque ouais mon
cavalier a que j'aime bien qu'à eux deux
mais pourquoi pas avoir interverti om et
oursins ça peut être un coup de damman
et non c'est bien joué
comme pour les paliers à sa demande
daniel les appariements sont faits en
fonction de lelo complètement alors
comment on pourrait parier à se parer à
ça à mon avis ce serait assez simple
mais bon ça c'est passé dix ans qui a
toujours pas été retenu mais ce serait
d'avoir un système de cette c'est à dire
que le premier en 4 par exemple premier
set 17 de quatre partis c'est pas mal et
donc là on serait déjà proche du 2 sets
0 pourrait faire ça en deux ou trois
sets gagnants suivants il faut faire les
calculs après mais comme ça les matches
là lé match pour le vent la première
heure c'est assez passionnant c'est
juste qu'on va rentrer dans le moment où
on risque de bientôt arriver au moment
où c'est la catastrophe a là encore que
cette partie à mon avis ça peut le faire
parce que les noirs sont quand même un
peu un peu au rupteur ce qu'on peut
jouer qu'à et j'ai un cavalier f3 ici
attention tout de même va peut-être
prendre un f4 parfait client combien de
points gagnants alors ça va ça marche
pas en terme de points ça marche en
termes de deux temps il ya un temps et
un temps de jeu y'a pas de dia pas de ya
pas de point qui permet de gagner le
match s'est laissé du temps de jeu et je
me demande si h s'inquiète un coup ici
parce que l'idée c'est que sur fou prend
cavaliers prend dame prend la tourache
un peu à la grille tchouk un peu ses
tubes qu'on avait vu dans la vidéo sa
partie contre naka pour à l'anc et sage
7 en force qui à mon avis serait pas mal
parce que la sueur h56 doivent si elle
doit faire [ __ ] en d3 dame prend des 3
je pense c'est plutôt sympa pour irina
qui avait réussi à se débarrasser du fou
de cases blanches là ce petit vis-à-vis
là et qui commence a réussi à faire
jouer la dame quoi que ce serait pas
encore fini à la rigueur elle a fait
trois pour commencer dame là et h5 bon
sa force la même chose
et finalement ça elle a introduit le
coup f3 qui est pas forcément un coup
qu'on avait envie d'introduire parce que
ça affaiblit un peu le pion de trois
peut-être vous pouvez faire h 500 le
faire après je rate et peut-être quelque
chose hein
mais plus tu tues tu perds tu tues
disparaît de l'écran et vanina c'est
incroyable elle à l'expression de son
visage n'a pas changé d'un poil g5
mais peut-être un coup comme g4
maintenant bref de g4 mais je pourrais
2,5 tout cas tu pensais tout recettes
elle veut faire tour au 8 c'est vrai que
c'est dommage on se coiffe 3 quand même
quoique peut-être y aurait quand même
fallu le faire qui sait c'était pas si
facile à affaires tourache 1 tour 8
thèmes qu aux cavaliers g2 elle a fini
par reculer mais la tourache un qui est
bien placé ce qu'elles empêchent qu'un
voyage 3 et chalon l'empêchent pas quel
âge trois échecs mais cavaliers h trois
échecs elle veut partir avec le roi et
tout est défendu parce que les cavaliers
tiennent bien les cibles annoncées les
noirs qui ont du mal à qui ont du mal à
frapper parce que toutes les pièces sont
max et on ne réussit pas à améliorer
donc elle fait ces cinq c'est bien joué
elle veut que le full viennent taper sur
trois elle veut venir convergé sur cette
faiblesse donc ces cinq c'est pour ça
comme on pouvait comme on peut pas finir
le coup parce que 3 et des blindés et g3
est blindé on vient dire ok t'as blindés
sabah maintenant on va on va venir
écarter le jeu on va faire une passe on
va faire une passe pour le fou qui va
venir en c5 attaqué la g4 qui est joué
maintenant ça permet de fermer l'accès à
la case h3 et à la case f5 aussi puisque
dame f5 pouvait dans certaines variantes
être une idée comment est ce que les
noirs vont continuer à présent parce que
s'ils prennent peut-être le cavaliere
reprend et va jaillir vers f5 nous il
défendra à eux trois ils attaquera le
roi g4 bien jouer way
est-ce qu'on est fous avec les noirs et
entend de sa dame bouger d'un projet 400
pas très bon pascal roy noir qui est mal
placée derrière par mon avis c'est
pourri donc elle fait ses quatre dames
f5 elle vient proposer les changes des
dames qui est accepté et g4 et b5 pardon
excusez moi
les blancs n'ont aucune attaque alors il
peut y avoir une idée de faire rage six
cavaliers quatre cavaliers h5 mais ça me
paraît long et en plus sur kavoshgar-4
on sera systématiquement prendre mon
café cavaliers c3 est elle bien attaquer
les deux faiblesses noir r b et c 3
excellent coup qui a été clairement raté
par par vanina et le pion des cinq
maintenant qui est indéfendable
est-ce qu'elle va apprendre des 5 ou b5
elle prend des seins qu'elle menace qui
est pro f6 fou j'ai trois échecs donc ça
échange
maintenant il ya f5 qui emprise ton coin
f5 est-ce que c'est jouable oui je pense
parce qu'on menace en f3 donc tourcoing
f5 paraît jouable
irina qui s'est encore mis très mal
autant un vu la pendule je sais pas qui
est favori de cette partie tourcoing f5
tatev catry sirois g4 qui va arriver
cavalli ou quatre échecs très
probablement pourquoi j'ai 4 me paraît
pas offrir vraiment plus values parce
que ça se mettra sur une case de
fourchette
après tour des 5 donc je vois pas
vraiment de plus value à roye g4 et
maintenant il ya peut-être des cavaliers
des deux qui vont rodez attention est
aussi b4 c3 public le pion aux trois
peut être en prison cette leroy qui
paraît elle n'a pas voulu se laisser
mettre dans un réseau le pion à vii elle
va le laisser il sert à rien et elle va
venir donner quelques échecs à roye f2
suroît eux deux il y avait prise là et
donc elle prend mais bon elle perd quand
même une qualité et leroy qui vient
aussi ce maintenant le roi qui va
pouvoir venir vers et fils peut-être en
cas de besoin pas obligatoire et b4 c3
qui arrive bien évidemment pour envoyer
le pion passé
la tour blanche qui essaye de faire des
dégâts mais à mon avis ça va pas bien
loin
je vois pas de vraie menace pour les
blancs peut-être que les gens peuvent
simplement jouer jouer le pion bon elle
protège comme le pion aux fl laisse pas
de de jeu elle met la tour en a 5 elle
va s'en prendre aux pions à les blancs
qui vont jouer leur va-tout avec le pion
le pion à achat va se prendre un petit
échec un petit échec en b3 elle va
perdre le pion et elle va dell va même
tomber bon c'était complètement foutu
parce que la tour pouvait très
facilement veut dire intervenir sur la
colonne h au cas où donc
donc voilà nouvelle victoire de vanina
qui prend vraiment le large là il ya
plus de dix ans vidéo on n'a même pas le
frisson aujourd'hui pour pour irina sais
c'est vraiment massacre à la
tronçonneuse il me faudrait un petit e
il me faudra un petit pegi 18 pour pour
ce match parce que là ça me paraît
vraiment être le massacre 1 c'est assez
situe à repartir en j'ai envie de dire
en sip quoi mais tu as plus rien à voir
là pour les ans on dirais tu perds tu va
repartir en slip tu as plus de chemises
s'appuyèrent là tu repars en string si
on reste dans le dans le thème du speech
est féminin lasser c'est la catastrophe
à damas et celle écrasa da c'est la pls
c'est la pls cosmique il n'y a même pas
de match c'est une domination de gouina
sans appel sans appel mais bon c'est
elle et la compétition on n'y peut rien
les amis il ya des matches à des joueurs
qui sont qualifiés pour la compétition
qui ont le niveau
mais ça arrive ça arrive des massacres
après ce qu'on n'est pas à l'abri d'un
milan liverpool d'une remonte à la de
folie j'ai envie de vous dire non
j'ai envie de vous dire non vous me
connaissez quand je pense qu'il ya une
possibilité d'avoir un un peu de matches
un peu de suspense je vous le dis bien
évidemment mais mais mais kankankan
séquences et des tels massacres
je ne vous mens pas vous tenir en
haleine je vois pas de scénario c'est le
scénario des partis moi qui m'inquiète
le plus que comme je vous le disais
quand vous avez des scénarios
quand vous avez des scénarios où c'est
chaud ou sajoo machin bon je vous dis il
ya beaucoup qu'il ya des choses qui
peuvent arriver machin mais là là là je
vois je vois je vois pas quel moment
irina mis en danger juste un tuyau de
regarder en train de regarder que je
chante pas en train de rater quoi que ce
soit d'important
donc j'ai juste un petit coup d'oeil à
l'aspect technique de la chose mais oui
je vois je vois pas de scénario de
scénario de retournement de situation
quelconque
après on n'est jamais à l'abri de rien
mais mais je vois je vois pas je vois
pas comment je vois pas comment ça
pourrait arriver ici cette partie la
banda des pions pendant récupérer tous
les trucs que je ça c'est bon je rajoute
un oeil sur twitch pour vérifier que le
sim soit bon alors ça c'est bon là c'est
pas moi qui avais de problème donc on
est bon ici je suis fixé dans la bonne
catégorie dans le machin et j'ai pas
fait d'erreurs et on va se relancer à
fond dans le match on fait une petite
respiration au passage on et 2300 sur le
live quelle folie
bon bah n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit
faux l'oim les mecs si vous êtes nouveau
et ouais parce qu'on a réussi à
récupérer la première page donc grand
merci à vous d'être si nombreux et de
rester ça tombe ça à écouter les mecs si
vous êtes nouveau et que vous tombez là
dessus j'ai envie de dire
les premières pages switch ça fait tout
de suite la différence je vais vous dire
on n'est pas ton n'a pas trop de chance
en fait de tomber la première page c'est
un peu le hasard on tombe sur la
première page sur un match
j'ai envie de dire je puis par me dire
pourri parce que le match en soit on
voit on voit une belle performance de la
joueuse russe mais un match aussi
déséquilibré
donc du coup ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est n'hésitez pas dans le chat à poser
des questions on peut aussi en profiter
vu que le match n'est pas n'est pas
n'est pas fou fou pour pour parler un
petit peu d'échec d'un point de vue plus
large
je crois qu'elle est fort francophile un
hic smarteo vanina c'est pour ça qu'à le
drapeau français
n'hésitez pas à poser des questions
dans le chat et d'en profiter pour
si vous êtes nouveau échec pour nous
dire on dire ce que vous en pensez si
vous pensez du match et donc voila voila
je copie maxime fait je m'entraîne pour
le stream avec maxime de vendredi 18h
donc vendredi 18 heures s'ils voulaient
repasser il y aura le le numéro 5
mondial qui commentera avec moi un des
tout meilleurs joueurs français de tous
les temps
après difficile de comparer les époques
qui la réunion de ces chèques sont ma
plus grande passion way est probablement
alors jusqu'à 10 quelle couleur par
rapport aux joueuses alors vanina sait
la joueuse de gauche la blonde
donc c'est celle qui a les blancs pour
le moment et heroes 2 cas c'est la brune
la joueuse de droite alors qu'en russie
à moscou il ya un championnat tous les
ans d un match entre les brunes et les
blondes bon numéro quatre mondial même
le tableau est peut-être un peu savent
où ça bouge beaucoup les classements sur
mon numéro 4 5,6 à change sourds dame
prend des quatre essais jolie dame prend
des 4 de heroes checa sur fion prend il
ya tout reprendre il y avait je vais le
montrer sur qui on prend y avait le
fameux match du couloir qui gagnaient la
partie donc petite déconcentration de
vanina qui perd deux pions et ça va
probablement l affaire h4 l'a envoyée
mais ça va probablement permettre à
heroes cas d'un petit peu revenir dans
le match
ce qui n'est pas pour nous déplaire
petites tactiques comme ça un petit dame
prend des quatre jolis qu'est-ce que je
fonde l'ouverture sicilienne par écoute
pourquoi pas un toutes les ouvertures
sont jouables c'est une bonne ouverture
par ici est ce qu'on peut faire
tour des huit avec l'idée sur d'un match
5 de faire échec ça échec la tour j'ai
trois pages web via dame prend g3 sur
watch 3 il ya peut-être des tours
détroit qui arrivait et le roi comment
cette malle et suroît g1 il n'y a pas
trop d un
donc peut-être faire la même avec tours
c'est 8 elle a fait autour des 8 à l'est
il faut peut-être aller prendre et
remettre le ranger un même si c'est
moche façon perdu pour perdu je me dis
toujours je me dis toujours on y va
ok il ya un petit bug merci de martinez
dans le tchat avec deux caméras
voilà ces cérémonies merci à vous mais à
l'ouverture française toutes les
ouvertures sont jouables au début après
ça dépend ce que vous voulez faire quoi
avec vous ouverture mais un niveau de
base vous pouvez jouer à peu près tout
des cinésites et pas faire de 4,5 pour
commencer c'est pas mal à vous pouvez
faire là car au calme je trouve c'est
bien donc autour des 8 3 h de 9,6 g iii
je crois que la dame était bien place en
c3 je suis pas pour l a pas fait tour
des deux devait y avoir une raison qui
m'échappe
un truc qui marche pas trop ces dames un
tour des reins si vous le faites parfois
parce qu'il ya juste d'amener froid qui
couvre à elle veut rentrer dans la
finale de dame qui va être assez simple
à gagner je pense on peut prendre
prendre même à la rigueur et à et on
aura pas vraiment de problème parce que
raja mais un échec
donc normalement la finale qui devrait
l'en qui devrait gagner finale dames
assez facilement
elle fait d'amis ci qui est très bien
aussi un atout gagnant du coup un
surtout reprend des cinq la dame prend
2,3 ces tireurs dame f3 mais bon il y
avait tellement c'est juste dur de créer
une menace pour les blancs je crois que
l'objectif pour les blancs c'est de
réussir à créer une menace dans cette
partie à partir de maintenant
qu'elle crée une annonce mesdames
proches inquiets même pas une menace
parce qu'il ya des problèmes de échec
mais roddick à qui ce même à l'otan
voilà elle va faire dame 17 j'imagine
essayé d'encaisser un pion là-bas
l'assomption g5 et perdu mais c'est
incroyable elle galère a gagné avec les
noirs c'est quand même mauvais signe
j'ai envie de dire même cette victoire
est pas et pas très bon signe veut
ravoir wager un j'imagine ce que suroît
g2 elle veut faire dame des cinq échecs
mais sur oisiens il y aura il y aura des
5 ou à 5 et affaire d'âme des huit dames
d'amd vidame des 8 ou a4 en premier puis
elle va faire d'amd 8 d'am dam dam des
huit mais bon le truc c'est que les
noirs se mettre mal autant quand même
elle se met vraiment mal autant et j'ai
envie dire c'est enfin une victoire sur
une une petite déconcentration de
l'adversaire mais c'est pas une victoire
rassurante au final qui va qui va qui va
arriver parce que on n'a pas
l'impression que les noirs étaient
vraiment en contrôle
on a plus l'impression d'une joueuse qui
galèrent à convertir un avantage qui
était pas si compliqué que ça j'imagine
et c'est vrai que c'est un peu un peu la
galère pour le concrétiser et trouve pas
ça rassurant vanina là qui a réussi à
bien se placer à la réussi à bloquer le
deux contre un et est maintenant c'est
dur pour les noirs elle veut vraiment
péché dame f6 dam des cats un live
ailleurs damev six échecs maintenant
date des huit ça va être pénible c'est
vraiment là il va y avoir du talent f6
le retour elle va pas réussir à gagner
ça ou si quand même alors à mettre la
dame un f5 à ce qu'elle dure ne pas
gagner sa dame c7 ça va le faire
quand même hein alors ça devrait ça
devrait y arriver va revenir un fils
avec la dame n'en rage 2 3g un du
magazine elle va avoir du mal à gagner à
la plus beaucoup de temps elle a réussi
à gagner le pion g5
ok ça c'est plutôt bien pour elle parce
qu'elle va réussir à récupérer une tonne
d chaque cas peut-être faire et qu'elle
revient en d4
j'imagine qu'ils allaient faire dame b 5
mais qui est donc là attention d'un
match 4 à dammaj 5l fed à 9,6 alors
repartir en des huit j'imagine elle
revient en d4 elle veut protéger son
pion au hay adams bref deux incroyables
mais c'était sûr qu'elle finirait par la
perdre même ça même ça elle peut pas
gagner ce soir
oh la la elle a tellement tellement
tellement tellement voulu assurer le
coup elle a tellement voulu assurer le
coup de deux avec les noirs ça sentait
que sa santé ça allait pas le faire sa
santé même ça elle gagne par m es là
c'est là c'est quand même c'est quand
même compliqué si tu peux pas gagner la
finale de dames avec deux pions plus la
finale écho plus là ça devient
je vous disais j'ai pas l'ombre d'un
espoir dans ce match et je me trompe pas
je me trompe pas trop je suis bon
pronostiqueur pour les matches des
chèques là pour ces matches là je sens
bien je sens bien la dynamique mais là
quand même quand même les amis cette
dame là qu'ils se donnent en un coup
perdre ça c'est quand même une faute
professionnelle à ce niveau là ça fait
huit ans c'est vraiment un écho plus ça
fait 8 1 et ouais là là là mon avis faut
avec daniela règne vienne et qu'il
arrête le match on sort ayrinhac rush
sur une civière
j'ai quand même douté non mais je
pensais qu'avec anne gagné la partie
je le cache pas elle va la gagner mais
j'ai senti qu'elle galéré j'ai senti
qu'elle galère et les amis bon bah c'est
moment de lâcher un petit polo sur la
chaîne à noter qu'on aura notre tournoi
blick stream ce soir la reine vitrine
qui sera exceptionnellement à 22 heures
avec un petit peu de ti au plus tard que
d'habitude à cause ou grâce à ce match
donc vous pouvez venir tous participé
sera bien évidemment sur la chaîne
bitstream sur ma chaîne perso n'hésitez
pas à aller voir peut-être quelqu'un va
donner un message laissé un message dans
le chat est allé là ses positions fois
les fonderies d'ahmed trois dames h3
allez faut essayer d'en gagner une au
moins j'ai envie d'y relever la tête
pour pour irina parce que là elle a
vraiment la tête la tête sous l'eau
vraiment la différence de niveau et est
assez assez grande mais là une position
vraiment agréable à jouer avec les
blancs à le faire j'ai cinq d'un mach 3
hervé pâture est oui je pense qu'il est
totalement démotivée ouais je pense
aussi franchement là c'est dur à mai à
ses quatre essais 3 j'avais pas vu moi
même
ok donc l envoi
ok c'est pas si grave en fait parce
qu'elle va envoyer fou prend h7 damage
cinq tours f3 avec la position blanche
paraissait assez intéressante
c'est chaotique pour les noirs dont
peut-être que les noirs vont tenter puis
on prend des trois pions pranger 6.36 ne
voulait pas laisser faire les fous prend
accède à mach 5 qui arrive et c'est
quand même assez chaotique a beaucoup de
pièces blanches qui arrivent mais bon
cavalier g4 c'était juste dame france et
2 mai fu c1 mais bon roi g7 en premier
oui oui elle a raison parce que s'ils
avaient cavaliers price is et d'un match
5 qui rôdait on croit g7 la position est
un peu dingue
donc
il ya plus de monde pour le speech est
féminin complètement dommage qu'ils
aient pas l'hypothèse à ce compte là
à ce compte là c'est de toute façon
c'est pour ces pour se prendre la foudre
comme ça on aurait pu avoir voté sur la
caméra ça aurait été pas mal voté ce qui
est vraiment qui est vraiment dans le
malin qui est vraiment dans le dur
enfin qui sait pas qui attaqua les
droits pas le problème de l'aileron en
fait c'est que les blancs pas trop de
pièces
ils ont du mal à y arriver en fait sur
cette aile roi et sur qui on prend des
trois il va y avoir dame ces deux
j'imagine quand même pour forcer fous
ses reins et empêcher à la tour de ram
de revenir en interne leurs pions prend
drame ces deux double attaque pour
défendre tu fais pousser rhin mais du
coup ça ça revient pas et les noirs vont
avoir le loisir de faire cavalier cinq
tours g8 3 et fuite est attaqué dans
quoi et j'imagine que les noirs sont
mieux une nouvelle fois finalement
herrina qui est vraiment dur et non mais
on s'en sort plus avec les commentaires
est ce qu'on peut faire tout
resserrement sur tours c'est un
j'imagine droit de faire plus en france
et 2 du coup pareil le pion ces deux va
être un peu pénible un jour tu devras
après avoir un temps pour le récupérer
tes mal en fait t'es mal partout tour c1
est mon bateau français 2 j'imagine un
ace que je les infos sur le manga échec
qui devrait sortir avec kasparov non je
sais que c'est des gens qui habite pas
loin de chez moi qui le font parce
qu'ils sont sur nice mais personne ne
m'a contacté par rapport à ça donc
aucune idée
bon du greffe et tous rêvent de donc
c'est pour ça elle veut pas se faire
perdre sa tour - un coût qui me plairait
ici avec les noirs cette fois à 6 pour
faire foot est roi et replacer mon fou
ça c'est mon côté c'est mon côté replace
âge de fou mais elle fait h saint nom
qu'elle veut gagner une pièce mais
peut-être on peut jouer tout rejet de
ici à mes pions prend dame prend
cavaliers g6 on va manquer de matos elle
est vraiment forte vanina dans ses
positions
c'est un de ces gros point fort elle
joue vraiment bien
elle fait peur à même mm même les
meilleurs joueurs du circuit en or et
auront peur de vanina dans ses positions
il ya beaucoup d'attaquants tf6 alors
lisez sur roy prend à la ferme tom price
5 ariane menace am-dam g5 maths mais
ajuste tour g8 ça j'avais vu persos sont
des ventes que j'ai calculé lajus
cavaliers f5 et on va pouvoir partir
avec le roi entre 7 et 17 et les noirs
qui ont juste une pièce de plus l
attaque
ça va faire 9,1 ça me rappelle un match
car yakine nepomniachi pour ce qu'il
avait suivi et non menace même cavalier
j'ai trois échecs ou puis on prend et
toura suite
non mais ça fait ça fait ça fait dur là
là c'est dur nam revient émane entourage
suite j'imagine et une possibilité 3g de
force et fait tour j'ai deux ne s'est
pas forcé ce que ça empêche kg 3 aussi
un tour qui revient juste me l'a juste
une pièce de plus pour les noirs c'est
c'est un massacre
quelle part avec le roi d'un camelot
pioncer 2 qui va tomber mais bon il y
avait dedans mais ces pièces-là 2 + 1 cs
et c'est affreux 1
d'ailleurs et peut-être cavalli j'ai 3
pour les noirs un moment donné qui n'a
pas vu le jour
si le noir réussissent à ramener leurs
fous en jeu c'est fini elle va remettre
le cavalier vers 4 qui sera mieux placé
et c'est un jour ont réussi à faire x 6
à mon avis ce sera fini ça va changer
mais avoir un petit coup de roy quelque
part elle résiste pas mal dans cette
partie irina genre n'est plus en
présence la domination autant baisser la
domination de partout un lacet la
première partie où c'est plutôt ou en
étant mal elle joue plutôt bien mais le
truc c'est qu'elle a plus de temps et
c'est une nouvelle victoire
alors ça est ce que c'est la dernière
partie en 5 + 1
ouais et encore une partie en cinq plus
un ça va être la dernière de cette
cadence
donc pour le moment il ya neuf 9 buts à
1 c'est un vrai massacre
pourquoi est ce que le niveau des
féminines fait au masculin bob
j'ai déjà parlé plein de fois il ya
plein de théories différentes sur le
sujet mais personne n'y a pas de
consensus en sait rien en fait
voilà nos fins et c'est quand même
l'armée c'est cher quand même c'est cher
payé mais après sur le contenu c'est pas
volé c'est pas volé forcément sur le
contenu
est ce que c'est vrai enfin c'est
vraiment est vraiment qu'une jouer sur
l'échiquier quoi quand sera le prochain
tour blitz stream non d'atlanta nice ce
soir à 22h ce soir à 22h20 que tu
viennes sur le stream pour avoir toutes
les informations pour arte inscrire donc
je veux une de ses positions un petit
peu symétrique en termes de structure de
pions et les blancs qu'un petit plus
tout simplement parce qu'ils ont un
léger avantage de développement quoique
ici ce n'est même pas non et qui sait ce
doit être ça avait plus ou moins correct
les noirs qui met la tour ans et 8 vise
mais dans le viseur de la dame madame
ans et c'est de ma chance et un la
dernière partie rambert 8b un les dames
amont et qui vont repartir par là bas
élan qui pourrait aussi faire un dam des
deux dames e1 revenir plus central c'est
aussi possible d'amener 2 qui menacera
cavale et prend b5 et d'un prend des six
donc il faut faire attention je vous
prends à trois prix f3 roi h2 j'avais
pas vu non plus dans l'agro et 5
déconcentration des joueuses et du
commentateur sa réponse à un peu fou
pour être franc je sais qu'un mât c'est
évident mais forcément il ya vraiment
une vraie baisse de pression un tel que
ce soit quand on joue mais même quand on
commande fait c'est même phénomène dans
le match et quand même c'est comme ça ce
me plier tata un moment de surtout que
là on arrive à la dernière partie où tu
bloques un peu parce que parce que parce
que l'enjeu baisse donc j'ai trois c'est
logique peut faire rager de et tour h1
peut être attaqué
alors tu mises sur qui en grande
favorite du speech est féminin vanina
quand même un sens précédente
est ce que je ferais l'aréna de ce soir
je suis pas sûr parce qu'après trois
heures et demie de commentaires c'est
pas sûr que cela fasse ailleurs il a
fait vraiment qu'elle a gagné barry
versé 4 mais c'est pas sûr qu'elle la
gagne franchement c'est pas sûr c'est
qu'ils de jouer entre eux et un clic en
de merci de me répondre ouais c'est ça
ces deux joueuses et c'est un
commentateur bon donc c'est vraiment un
pion net de plus c'est une position plus
agréable pour les noirs mais il faut
encore la finir mon cas on peut tenter
un truc vicieux dame 17 et sur fouet
trois dames prend f3 prise en f3 et
cavaliers des deux échecs à l'efo
commencé à tenter des pièges là pour
irina faut commencer à faire des pièges
des amis et dames bessette en plus c'est
même pas qu'un piège qu'on pourra voir
du cavalier des deux cavalières 3 dans
tous les cas à les dames bessette ça m'a
l'air d'être sympa tosh comme coup ou
damas huit a laissé la même idée allez
allez dame prend un cavalier d2 à
l'étoile a enfin une tactique dont une
partie complètement raté de la part de
de vanina et ça fait plaisir pour pour
irina qui du coup reprend du poil de la
bête et marc et marquent un deuxième
point dans le match et normalement ça
devrait être la dernière des cinq plus
un c'est exact donc on va faire une
pause de cinq minutes et on sera de
retour donc enfin je serai de retour
dans 5 minutes pour pour la suite du
match et le 3 + 1 donc rester là ne
bougeait pas on se retrouve très
rapidement à tout de suite l'élite
[Musique]
mais les mecs on est reparti pour pour
la deuxième partie du match voit que les
c'est encore en petite pub sur la chaîne
officielle donc on va attendre deux
petites minutes j'en profite pour vous
montrer le tableau que je vais pouvoir
agrandir comme ceci est donc on va avoir
sur le tableau que ce qu'on est en train
de regarder
c'est la partie droite du tableau donc
la gagnante de ce match probablement
gouina rampe rencontrera lors du
prochain tour irin accroche donc ce sera
le irina cauchemar qu'est avec les
caméras sont à mon tour rencontrera
kosteniuk pardon je m'en sors plus et
donc côté gauche danielian qui a éliminé
l'agglo à la surprise générale pourrait
affronter marie ce bague la française
qui jouera jeudi contre arica cela étant
dit le match va repartir et et on va y
aller mais on va y aller on a tenté de
joueuses reprennent on voit le score 9 2
donc
donc ce match va repartir 9,2 je sais
pas ce qu'on peut espérer de ce match et
parce qu'on peut trouver de de
passionnant c'est parce qu'on peut
espérer que crush gagne un mini match
peut-être qu'elle gagne le 3 + 1 pour
essayer de trouver trouver de l'intérêt
ouais si elle revient à -5 points 4
pourquoi pas après 1
on sait jamais le match pas complètement
fini on peut espérer qu'elle revient un
peu mais comme je vous disais moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est vraiment sur le contenu
bon là maintenant la cadence va changer
et on va voir ce que ça va donner
pourquoi ce que les caméras sont mal
classés les joueuses là pour la peine
qui ce cadre mal mais valentina qui
s'est bien cadrés 1 est personnellement
du coup qui arrive en c3 a passé 6 bon
donc
après b5 ça va retomber dans une boue de
vigny qu'avoir 5h 6h 4g cinq cars et les
projets cinq pions franges et 5 francs
g5 cavalli b17 fou aux 7 c'est aussi
jouable c'est un autre coup c'est un
coup un peu plus moderne à ce que je
sais faire qui a repris de la mode en
tout cas ces derniers temps avant
c'était plutôt qu'à et b17 danse cojo et
comme ça donc la position qui est assez
chaotique d'un côté les noirs ont plus
de pions ranger en h
donc le plus rage qui peut être passer
un jour le fou g2 qui assez fort dans la
diagonale et je sais pas trop ce que
fait valentina parce que là j'ai
l'impression que sur flu bessette est
déjà qui prend b5 et donc si vous
baissez à tes jouets qu'ils éprouvaient
5 va arriver et je sais pas où elle
s'est trompée ce que fawcett s'est pas
la vente que je joue moi je vous paye et
17 si on prend 1,6 mais là il semble y
avoir un problème peut qu'éprouver 5 est
quand même possible et il semble y avoir
un problème pas ce qui se passe qui
prend bessin puisse amener sera cueilli
ses sept et du coup donc et qu'elle
prend b 5 tours b 8 peut-être cavaliers
ses trois tours prend b2 mais ouais ok
peut-être ça existe en réalité comme je
sais pas c'est pas la vente que je vous
mangerez attaquer et 17
peut-être que ça existe mais du coup
elle commence par rock presse que
j'allais vous proposer l'idée c'est que
du coup sûr plus on prend des quatre
cahiers prend des cinq tours b 8 curieux
cavani prend des 4 et bien sûr que les
messins qui a toujours tout retour baies
vitrées l'a fait petit rock faut pas se
tromper il n'y a pas de pions devant le
roi noir mais
mais il n'est pas si facile que ça
attaquait parce que la dame vieille bien
au graal va peut-être repartir vers g7
ou g6 oui pour garder un oeil là-dessus
et peut-être peut-être qui on prend et
d'amd quatre peut-être c'était possible
auquel a fait f4 c'est vrai que c'est
pas idiot sur fion enfin il veut faire
dame prend la dame va être bien placé
sur qui on prend elle va faire tout
reprend qu'elle fait 5
manqué
que faire j'ai fait piéger 5 4 mais
c'est vrai que c'est pénible a
maintenant parce que les noirs ont
réussi peut-être faire j'ai quatre mais
qui regarde à faire cavalier si socke et
dessins que j'aime bien dessin il faut
réussir à tout faire péter la forêt us
ira faire sauter la position noir mais
peut-être à faire qu'il c5 et cavaliers
detroit mais sera peut-être pas si grave
on pourra peut-être tout faire péter
avec g4 un moment donné j'aime bien des
cinq au kef où bessette
maintenant est ce qu'on peut faire
cavalier
il faut tout faire péter
clairement ça me semble que la position
noir tient à pas grand chose
cavalli aussi ça lui a fait retour
quelque part j'aurais vii ce que tours 8
elle peut pas donc elle va mettre la
tour eiffe sadi imagine ouais c'est le
cas elle prend ses six france et 6 à
manger un hoquet danse avatar prend
aussi ça va et là dessus il ya d'amd ci
soit et c'est bien là ce qu'elle fait là
c'est très bien ce qu'elle a joué dans c
était maintenant elle va elle va
renforcer mais attention à pas se
prendre un tour et fils méchant tout
réussi ça le fait comment pour défendre
maintenant
ben je crois qu'elle s'est fait piéger
la pièce bêtement ça semblait bien joué
mais envoyer un petit risque avec ce
cavalier aussi ce qui restait mal et
vanina qui est tellement forte en
tactique d'amd 4 et/ou reprend aussi ce
qui est à me prend 1,7 et dame prend 1,7
et c'est ok a peut-être alors même que
trois justement maintenant pour ok y'a
peut-être fou prend c'est si ces machins
damev 7 mai vanina qui est vraiment
vraiment bien vendre est une pièce de
plus sûrement joué un coup comme
cavalier f6 maintenant
elle va préparer petit à petit 3 pour
envoyer le pion salut à pollen qui
s'arrêtent de regarder vanina vahina
vanina c'est le surnom de gouny n'a en
fait c'est son surnom pour les débutants
m et bon séjour de commenter un truc de
professionnels pour les débutants
débutants 1 carrillo sarkorzy des
sections d'un refrain f cet accueil
price est donc le truc sera pas en prise
et sur damas six pour attaquer la tour
peut-être fou bessette qui protégera la
tour et menacera la dame dans le premier
set car il y prend f7 tous rêvent d un
il ya juste une pièce de plus pour les
noirs et ça va gagner très
tranquillement 6 h trois tours g8
elle va s'en prendre option g la tour
qui va venir angers 6 et ça va gagner ok
c'est une nouvelle victoire pour pour
vanina ça fait plus 8
c'est quoi le timer en bâton
bah c'est le temps que les joueurs on
pourra le timer la part dont le timer en
bas c'est le temps qui reste en cadence
de trois plus un pour ce pour ce
tiers-temps pour ce segment du match du
coup le cahier qui varient 24 et qui va
revenir un f6
france et 3 français 3 qu'avaya six
cavaliers ou quatre au café fougue
quatre possibles aussi l'idée c'est
d'échanger les fous de cases noires de
cases blanches pardon mais c'est pour
les noirs d'échanger des coups de casque
blanche et de laisser les blancs avec le
fou c3 qui est pas forcément le plus
fort mais les blancs qu'ils peuvent avec
ses 5 b4 vanak a parfois joué comme ça
avec le move est fou et puis ils ont
comme au foot parce qu'il est derrière
les pions et et jouer comme ça avec le
mauvais fouet puis poussé et puis poussé
prendre de l'espace
bon la position qui est sensiblement
équilibré b55 ou hamas est responsable
mais elle prend la casse c4 et là encore
elle a pas une mauvaise position avec
les noirs hors-la-loi hésité avec fous
des cinq meilleurs des prêts mais que 4
et elle va pouvoir mettre le cavalier en
d5
quel dessein kefu b2 key qui va revenir
en quatre pour ces deux tours c'est un
f5 mon four b2 donc les noirs qui ont
mis leurs pions sur blanc est il qu'on
fout de cases noires donc c'est assez
sympa mais ils ont un problème c'est le
pion c6 qui va se faire martelé la tour
qui arrive en c1
et là il va y avoir 4 qui va arriver
ou pas on est très probablement le 4 qui
va arriver mais quoique pions prend
cavaliers prend et ce avec le plus heavy
sort peut-être trois ou quatre plutôt
pour les blancs pour essayer de chasser
le cavalier est peut-être jouer un jour
des cinq pour s'ouvrir le fou donc
j'imagine que le plan va être trois ou
quatre pour chasser ok cavaliers f3 peut
avoir l'idée de jouer cavalier 5-fu
prend et ouvrir le pion mettre le pion
aux 5 pour repasser le fou devant et
ramener le couvert des six ça peut être
une idée
c'est probablement ce qu'a choisi vanina
donc
gueye 5 donc ça prend prend et va mettre
le fou en d4 est peut-être passé en c5
et des six seraient fous des quatre
pouces et 5 fu des six doigts il va
réussir
et oui j'ai interagir un peu moins avec
le chat quand je commande des matchs
parce que forcément on est là pour
commenter le match dont je regarde un
peu vos messages mais on n'est pas en
mode si tu veux plus interagit avec le
tchad peut-être à 21h30
tu pourras venir sur ma chaîne perso il
y aura un autre stream 21h40 et la duke
ont interagi ira plus là quand ça joue
sajou 1
donc j'essaie un coq et les noirs qui
vont envoyer les pions bonsoir pas de
maxime qui ne tirent pas sera ouais bah
ouais mais du coup c'est sur ma chaîne
perso donc f3 ok ça veut elle veut
fermer le jeu quoi sur f4 et avoir eu
quatre
sarah de plutôt bien se passer pour les
blancs cette histoire là ou pas je sais
pas quel point elle va mettre le foin
ans et 5
je pense à peut-être réparer ou quatre
pour chasser le cavalier elle le fait
direct à tous pas fou c'est 5
y'a pas bête hein mais sur pions prend
elle peut elle peut prendre du plomb
mais elle peut prendre de la dame aussi
d'ailleurs maintenant je cavaliers qui
repart elle peut prendre un f5 puis
prendre en b 6 puis mettre la lada -4 et
complètement vie c'est le pion sur damas
quatre direct c'est peut-être cavaliers
c4 donc elle va se débarrasser du
cavalier d'abord pour l'éviter mais pour
pour éviter qu'ils viennent aidé à me 4
maintenant le pion c6 est vissé contre
attaque sur le pion aux 5
il ya deux écoles soit on fait tour c5
et on continue notre petit jeu de
pression tranquille soit en jouant f4
moi j'aurais plutôt choisi pour ces cinq
je pense bon je vais tourner un tour des
six après mais mon tour ses cinq as
peut-être tour des huit et la tour qui
arrive en d2 il faut calculer d'autres
choses auraient fait tout re 1 donc
maintient pour le moment la menace
elle maintient la menace en ces six là
il va y avoir g4 maintenant peut-être
est d'alger d'alger six dames no 6 a
laissé sa chasse la tour n'a toujours
pas et on va réussir à conques et ses
pions réussissent et ça va faire 11,2 et
les derniers espoirs d'irina crush qui
sont en train de de s'envoler
s'il existait encore parce que ce début
de cadence 3 plus simples où on aurait
pu expérimenter s de régime pour la
joueuse russe
c'est tout simplement pas arrivé c'est
même plutôt le contraire qui se passe
elle augmente encore son avance elle
était à + + 7 maintenant et à +9 je vois
pas je voyais déjà pas dans quel monde
elle revenait au score mais je me disais
un mauvais début de période endroit plus
sain elle revient à +5 et puis après de
+5 ça stabilise en bullet tu refais le
tueur fait l'écart ou bon il peut il
peut arriver des choses c'est ça reste
ça reste une compétition
il peut y avoir des surprises mais le
problème la sefa c'est vraiment le
scénario du match qui fait que ça ça
enchaîne s'enchaînent ça enchaîne un
ouais ça fait ça fait plus neuf
c'est vraiment beaucoup hein ça fait
vraiment beaucoup
c'est moche
bon mais ce qu'il ya un fou price qui a
été ratée je crois pas parce que le
cavaliere fuite défendez le pion hc
atteint donc cette position alain quiros
est est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
questionnaire cavaliers ou cinq
cavaliers leibstadt f3 maintenant que
quatre peut-être c5f 4 une idée pour
jouer pour l'espace à fond elle commence
par être quatre à laisser pas mal joué
ça donc les blancs qui ont essayé jouer
pour f6 et c5
prise d'espacé 6
elle va contrer au centre caf 6e 5
essayer en tout cas alors où va le
cavalier puisque prenant 17 c'est aussi
possible ce que cavalli prend il pas
possible avoue prend h7 qui traîne donc
on peut prendre puis on vous prend et
jouer jouer jouer à eux quatre ans les
blancs sont clairement mieux il ya un
gros avantage des espaces donc
ça et maintenant e5 voilà qui va arriver
c'est un peu dangereux de c'est un peu
dur pour les noirs là qu'ils ont quand
même toutes leurs pions sur blanc envoyé
le fou de cases blanches qui est
complètement qui est complètement
bloquée je vais avec les boues comment
on perce maintenant parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on peut jouer avec b 4 à 4 des 5
elle peut jouer des deux côtés de
l'échiquier et noir comme c'est de
réagir de jouer actifs
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont venir à tours fc 1
j'imagine portier pas forcément utile
d'ailleurs comment est-ce qu'on
progresse en fait c'est ici c'est une
forteresse là que les noirs ont mis en
face en face de nous il faut réussir à
la percée il faut réussir à la percée
donc pas facile pas facile de percer
cette forteresse tour des deux tours b 1
qui arrive mais il faut trouver une idée
pour percer peut-être faire jouer b5 un
moment donné mais bon ça crée beaucoup
de des changes alors qu'ils n'ont pas
vraiment d'idée un pour les noirs le
meilleur coup c'est juste de revenir en
17 avec le fou de jouer un coup lambda
tour à 8
alors pourquoi tour à 8
je vous avoue que ça m'échappe un peu
ok si c'est pour jouer peut-être b 5
puis à 5,5 est tour à tour b8 bon
c'était l'autre idée mais ça apporte bon
ça rapporte pas grand chose mais elle
veut juste jouer jouer des coups
peut-être elle peut mettre la dame ans
c7 et le kava lyon 17 pour essayer de
tout échanger sur la colonne b si elle
perd pas celle-là vanina avec les noirs
c'est déjà inquiétant mais c'est de pire
en pire elles fâchent 6 pour juger 5
mais ça crée aucune menace voilée là
avec les blancs faut envoyer un truc un
va faire renvoyer du bessin coup du c5
peut-être placé la dame en c3 et
envoyait ou lancer un don cancer la dame
elle protège sa elle protège sa les
envoyés du c5 youtube et cinq pardon la
tour qui pourra revenir en c2 au cas où
aller à l'envoi elle se décide enfin
alors qu'ils sont complètement foutue
j'ai l'impression c'est catastrophique
la position des noirs
alors comment va-t-elle défendre pour
ces sept ans elle prépare peut-être plus
on prend qui on prend et de prendre là
et surtout re c'est du aulas fait retour
ces huit tempo vous allez voir non je
pensais qu'elle allait faire ça tempo à
la pris 10 secondes qui va faire [ __ ]
ans le truc c'est que si elle fait tout
reprend et à peut-être fou quelque part
et qui attaque et après tour c7 est
affublé 5
bon ça devient très difficile alors la
torah 8 fou bessin qu'elle va remettre
la tour ans et 7
elle va prendre ici prendre ici prendant
b6 et elle tient encore incroyable parce
que sur foot points 8 dame prend 1,8
milliard à 4 qui traîne à la fin le
défend elle va faire cailler 17 pour
venir défendre ça mais elle cavayé qui
va arriver en d6 maintenant donc elle
fait dame c6 beaucoup mieux joué elle
cloue elle va faire tour c'est 8 mai
cavalier va quand même venir en b 5
affaires kg 6 j'imagine a essayé de
partir d'un côté de l'autre
mais ça mène à rien ça rime à rien les
noirs qui réussissent pas à contre
attaquer la position est trop dur le
cavalier qui varient vendée sissach wash
7 h 3 le faire j'ai 5 et 1 kg 6
maintenant où là c'est bizarre dame jeu
de dames d'alger 3 on est peut-être dû
dams et 2 c'est très étrange qu'elle a
fait maintenant les noirs qui tapent
tout elle va taper des 4l va ramener la
tour mon tour ces deux ou dame c4 et la
partie qui est complètement retourné et
rend jusqu'à la fin avec les blancs j'ai
pas trop compris le dame g3 ça semblait
complètement dominé mais s'est encore
perdu j'ai pas trop compris le h3
d'alger 3 c'est l'impression que tout
est lié à l'arrivée des six et que ça
allait et que ça allait faire mal et
finalement elle a fait un peu n'importe
quoi
c'est un peu bizarre
oui beaucoup il ya beaucoup de joueurs
mais c'est un peut caresser les
premières pages de toute façon quand
vous avez un instrument ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de monde n'y a pas
énormément de monde sur le chat c'est
souvent parce que 100 premières pages et
du coup l'effet première page fake ta
systématiquement beaucoup de monde mais
les gens restent peut-être 4 5 secondes
il vient y tape juste which il arrive
sur twitch et puis ils vont vers le
stream qui souhaitent regarder mais bon
espérons que les gens des nouveaux qui
reste après qu'on n'a vraiment pas de
bol dans le sens où pour les nouveaux
vous tombez vraiment sur le match le
plus déséquilibré de la saison c'est
vrai que c'est pas ce pas très palpitant
puisqu'il a déjà 10 points d'avance pour
pour la joueuse que voyant photo là on
se voit donc valentina wii minna et
c'est un gros c'est un gros écart 1 10
points c'est beaucoup et donc dès ses 10
points d'écart il reste à peu près une
heure de jeu mais c'est mathématiquement
déjà quasiment terminé et donc c'est
vrai que c'est plus difficile de rester
en jouer à suivre le match dans le sens
où c'est vraiment un massacre c'est un
peu l'équivalent si vous suivez le foot
y aurait chez pas moins 4 0 et on joue
la 75e minute quelque chose comme ça ça
a peu à peu près ça va c'est comme si
wayne match de foot ou match de basket
avec 25 30 points d'écart au début du
quatrième quart temps et pourquoi le
drapeau français me vanina francophile
donc à l'ami drapeau français
quel français si ce qu'avait processes
pas possible parce qu'il y aurait eu un
clouage et finalement les blancs qui
obtiennent peut-être à ils ont pas l
appel temps de jouer à 5 alors oui
peut-être qu'à la paille à l'arrêt
peut-être qu'un obtenu pour ses 1 2
bon ok qui va sûrement revenir vers ses
cinq les blancs les blancs qui ont une
position correcte après y'a pions isolé
confions isolé et le cavalier bk très
bien placé passe qui colmate le pion c6
ce doit être plus ou moins équilibrés
c'est dommage pour les blancs qui n'est
pas réussi à mettre le pion a5 et a6
genre ici s'ils avaient eu le temps de
jouer à 5
elle aurait pu mettre le cavalier en c5
et du coup mettre plus de pression sur
a6 malheureusement on n'a pas réussi à
le faire
cette qu'elle n'avait pas le temps est
peut-être un souci quelque part parce
que là du coup c'est vrai que lecavalier
b4 est super fort il défend la haye les
noirs vont pouvoir s'organiser pour
taper sur des 4 on voit que le foie pas
trop drôle à remplir ce fou ces quatre
là ça semble être un nouveau un nouvel
avantage assez assez gros pour pour
irina faut rejouer damas est ici
éventuellement protéger sa et attaquer
la cavalier des 5 alors laisse que les
blancs peuvent en profiter pour un peu
échangé non elle fait cavalier e 4 ça
rentre dans l'escarmouche tactique et
ses 5 îles à tours qui repart en a 7
et peut-être fou 2 way pour repartir
avec du fou g4 c'est possible c'est
possible de repartir pour du fou g4
[Musique]
donc tourbe et 8h fou j'ai quatre
peut-être fière d'un prend des huit
pardon j'avais raté aussi je suis un peu
le chat disais par les deux plus grands
joueurs de l'histoire sans inclure
suzanne si jeanne à la quasi tous les
records baja plutôt judith non non mais
c'est incroyable alors donné la tour en
1 c'est vraiment un massacre un bon
c'était 13 13 à 2 c'est un match
vraiment vraiment qui est trop à sens
unique
ouais mon humble avis c'est un match qui
mériteraient qui mériterait d'être
arrêté par ko 13,2 c'est quand même
c'est peut-être le plus gros massacre
des speechs à cela qu'on est en train de
vivre à quoi qu'il y avait eu nakamura
willy fans qui étaient un peu du même
acabit donc on voit le calendrier
prochain match qui sera donc le 30 jeudi
à partir de 18 heures en france dont
avilit arica qui jouera contre marie ce
bague la joueuse française
jacno c'en est fini mais moi j'ai vu
dame prend tour non mais ces essais du
rhin quand c'est comme ça c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment très dur hein c'est
vraiment très très dur hein
ça devient de la torture complètement
voyez la fiche du match
marie se bague à droite sur la petite
photo en dessous contre drones avilit et
holly fait mention peu avant des noms on
n'a pas le droit d'arrêter le match et
c'est un peu dommage
là tu devrais pouvoir jeter un jeu parce
que tu jettes ratèrent quoi tu chatterie
un pion j'ai même l'impression que c'est
dur de bien jouer pour goody nage
impression que les deux joueuses là sont
complètement out as quickly ans qu'alain
tête séparées des hommes et des femmes
aux échecs va y aller les tournois à les
tournois hommes sont mixtes 1 ils sont
pas séparés à l'orgue ivo karlovic pose
une question est-on plus performants
d'après toi aux échecs si on joue le
matin le soir ou la nuit
les joueurs ont dit leur préférence va
tout le monde a sa préférence à moi je
préfère le matin mais a beaucoup de
joueurs préfèrent l'après midi
donc ouais c'est une question de goût
c'est une question de rythme
ouais mais le truc c'est que judith
police fayçal est tellement plus forte
que suzanne donc enfin ce qu'aime une
grosse différence quoi parce que le truc
un peu plus le record le plus important
c'est le vélo le plus haut c'est un peu
le record qui compte en fait les autres
corps à la rigueur c'est que des records
jeunes le record de vélo c'est c'est le
record ultime c'est le record que tu
veux avoir trente et une minutes soit
exactement
oui ça a eu pour moi l'effet que les
arénas soit 21h 21h c'est un gros
handicap clairement 21h c'est vraiment
pas mon horaire c'est un vrai handicap
réf il est clair pour les deux
compétitrices à l'heure vanina je sais
pas s'ils allaient à moscou en ce
moment' si elle joue de chez elle ici
aller quelque part mais vu qu'ils ont
les candidats féminin qui démarre
bientôt ça se peut qu'elle soit encore à
moscou donc il serait une heure de plus
21h10 et irina crucial aux états unis
elle doit être en début d'après midi
ça va rendre ces thèmes un toit beaucoup
moins de bus urbains qui sait des maths
des veilleurs matinaux du coup que des
femmes et des hommes qui sont les plus
forts aux échecs pour qui connaît
tournant ni fabas et les hommes qui sont
beaucoup plus forts mais les tournois
masculins enfin les toits hommes et aux
amis qui se sont pas sont pas interdits
aux femmes le truc c'est juste qu'il n'y
a pas de femmes en ce moment au niveau
il ya une femme dont il parlait tout à
l'heure dans le chat qui s'appelait
judit polgar qui a dû jouer les tournois
de haut niveau mixte mais à l'heure
actuelle il n'y a pas de femmes qui est
un niveau suffisant pour jouer des
tournois de haut niveau en mixte de très
haut niveau en matière de haut niveau il
y en a mais de très haut niveau non
non c'est pas une régression d'horreur
10 fidan c'est juste une grosse
différence de niveau et c'est la seule à
avoir atteint le top 10 polgar
exactement cyril bon
dans la voir
on va avoir un tour c1
mais comment ça c'est quand même notre
sport soit pas mixer jusque sur
intelligence de jeu et pas de réels
efforts physiques bail que je sais pas
puisque ce message long débat ça c'est
pas un débat qu'on va voir maintenant
sur twitter mais c'est un long débat bon
est-ce qu'elle va pouvoir profiter de
son avantage cette fois-ci rinne a
encaissé pas mal joué ce qu'est en train
de faire valentina elle venir chasser la
tour avec son roi
mais elle va revenir colmatée ensuite et
irina qui est de nouveau mal autant il
n'y a pas qu'à l'étranger quatre là
peut-être une idée cacher ou peut-être
un cadeau à y avait six idées de cavani
6 6 qui a été ratée par tout le monde
sauf par irina voilà qui a enfin réussi
à placer une tactique
valentina qui sait peut-être un petit
peu un petit peu endormi entre
guillemets c'est pas facile quand on
attende avance de rester de rester
concentré elle va réussir à récupérer b2
mais elle va perdre des 5
non là je vois pas dans quel monde irina
raterait ça mais bon ce serait pas la
première surprise là y'a qu'un pion et
une qualité de plus c'est un très gros
avantage mais bon faut encore conclure
elle hésite
ces quatre échecs revenir avec le cac va
la faire flouer 5 mai roy croit ces
trois bons c'est un gros avantage pour
les blancs mais il ya presque plus de
temps
alors est-ce qu'elle va réussir à éviter
toutes les fourchettes oui mais elle a
plus beaucoup de temps mais le cavalier
va venir ans et 6 pour couvrir on voit
mal comment elle va faire cavalier f4
qui a eu six ménages us 3 3 ok elle a
pas fait 3 3 ça c'est bien joué h55 et
qui par an à 8 et alfio âge qui file
elle peut pas perdre ça quand même elle
peut pas perdre ça quand même
ok tour g8 elle va réussir à faire une
dame d'un macheath échec c'est sûr
qu'elle va faire sa valentine à damas 7
quel ans elle va gagner là quand même
mais ça aurait été chaud hein
là en plus c'est des coups qui sont
durables on a joué pour les noirs parce
que c'est des coups qui sont loin la
dame est plus difficile à déplacer
donc elle perd petit à petit du temps
fou des cinq échecs
ok allez tomber mais si elles avaient
réussi à faire food et cinq échecs
c'était plus perdant déjà il y avait
trois bouches dame si ces dames qu'on
s'est vite elle était peut-être même
gagnante avec les noirs déjà c'était
peut-être même gagnant avec les noirs
elle avait peut-être réussi à la
retourner mais elle est tombée parce que
j'aurais bien aimé vérifier avec l'ordi
mais je ne sais pas et chaque échec
prise échec la dame éprise à 8 de
l'autre côté
et si c'était déjà pas gagnant pour
valentina qui a fini par tomber
mais bon c'est pour vous dire une finale
avec une qualité un conte plus ça reste
très tendue d'après sa chair atteint la
toile c'est ce que j'ai vu alors c'était
c'était sa bella tola parti avait tourné
lancina les arnaques et la la la la
partie avec avec avec un tel retard
matériel c'est incroyable les amis c'est
incroyable les amis à quel point elle
est plus forte même avec une pièce de
moins on a l'impression que que ça
pourrait jouer c'est incroyable
incroyable incroyable ce cette
différence de niveau incroyable
incroyable c'est que j'ai l'impression
qu'elle est vraiment vraiment en mode
diesel ecoplus valentina qui en mode
diesel de marc ecko plus impressionnant
non mais c'est juste c'est juste rare de
voir quelqu'un sombre et autant puisque
la cci rina qui a largement le niveau
pour gagner ses positions 1
c'est simplement c'est simplement qu'à
la tête sous l'eau sera pas quitte au
fmc
c'est incroyable
incroyable je suis un peu sans voix en
fait donc là l'idée des blancs c'est
peut-être de jouer tour est joué sur le
clouage mais le truc c'est que le x e
set il couvre bien le clouage donc y
aura pas vraiment de cloyes sur la
colonne eux qui fait tout re 1 quand
même et là faut décider une bonne casse
pour la dame des six semble est logique
mais bon il y aurait cavalier e 4 dont
peut-être ans et 7 mai ans est saturé
tour c'est un donc peut-être b 8 mai b8
ça bloque la tour mes parents décision
qu'avait lieu 4 comme ça il fera dame 17
c'est pas grave c'est sûrement son idée
après vous calculez et peut-être qu'à eu
quatre dames g3 qui était intéressant et
qu'il met le foin à chis après mon c'est
une autre histoire tour des huttes
faites valider c'est sa c4 d'amd cette
dame g3 et sur roc faire flasher ce et
seule possibilité pour défendre ces g6
et du coup on gagne la qualité est la
partie n'est pas finie mais bon mais
maintenant on est on est introduit tour
d1 dames 17 et dames g3 et donc c'était
vrai voilà auquel le joue maintenant des
rocs fois h6 et peut-être faire rock
quand même hein c'est pas un peu tête
rock quand même ce que j'ai ici c'est
machin j'ai six fois ci c'est très moche
roi et fit c'est l'autre option entre
guillemets
on croyait fuite le problème c'est que
maintenant le roi il a commis là par ok
dans la tourache 8 rentre pas en jeu qui
est fou c'est 3
menace le pion g7 donc difficile à jouer
pour les noirs un cette histoire là
c'est vraiment pas évident si on fait f6
on va donner la casse j'ai six tours h7
c'est très moche le fou qu'il y en a
cinq qui menacent encore la tour
elle va sûrement faire cavalier g5 après
elle fait tour cn joue pour la colonne
s'est risqué pas idiot parce que si
elles rendent sur la colonne c'est ça va
être la cata 1cet ouvrage 7 qui est
quand même très moche on tour prend tout
reprend tourache si ces dames b 8 échecs
peut-être maintenant d'un mérité chez
qui paraît fort un café kg cinq des huit
ça va pouvoir faire mal parce que les
noirs ont pas avoir des milliers de
défense est fou des 6èmes tomates
peut-être dam des huit échecs qui était
vraiment vraiment vraiment fort aux
coups précédents
je sais pas c'était pas gagné direct jeu
juste regarder ce qu'on fait est en
train de me titiller de folie l'esprit
la dame des huit dames gates a gagné pas
direct ah et si c'était plus 10 sur
l'ordi c'est bien ce que je pensais tête
de truc qui gagnait sur le champ avec
smart et irina qui a gagné une partie à
l'arraché l'assam et sa vendange des
deux côtés un mage
c'est dur de critiquer valentina aussi
parce que quand le quand il ya un tel
écart franchement je me répète mais
c'est du rhin c'est vraiment dur mais
jamais eu ça va être un truc qu'il ya
une direct tu es là cavalier prend à vii
à la tête d'un truc qui gagne direct bon
mais la dame prend 2,5 à la tête d'un
truc qui gagne direct et c'est fini bon
ça aura pas le leur tour de dire il
n'aura pas duré longtemps elle a gagné
une partie à larache
elle repère direct et il ya de nouveaux
plus 11
il reste vingt minutes à jouer dans la
cadence
mais c'est fou hein cette différence 11
points d'écart 11 points d'écart
il n'y a pas eu d'adoption n'y a pas eu
de dix victoires d'affilée pendant ce
match donc l'adoption était ratée par
par vanina le caf qui comme un tel écart
est possible c'est pire que carlson
gousseïnov ouais même dans le contenu
c'est pierre carles scène gousseïnov en
fait bon goût c'est nos filets perdez
tout mais je sais pas il y à des parties
enfin après c'est dur de juger mais là
j'ai vraiment l'impression c'est
vraiment là domino domisse nationale à 2
2 partout valentina qui envoie qui a
envoyé une nims haut et qui envoie le
truc avec g5 f5 qui prend beaucoup d'
espaces allaient droit etc avaient lieu
deux qui est bien placé parce qu'ils
protègent ici ils protègent ici il
protège ici aussi éventuellement donc
c'est un cavalier multifonctions et
l'aurait peut-être avoir un petit coup
de f3 cavaliers prend et hg peut-être
peut être une idée qui sait pour avoir
mathieu cornette qui est spécialiste des
ragots zine même si ça c'est pas une
radio zine mais il connaît bien c'est ce
genre de position dans le ragot signaux
cavalli se rend à f3 là il n'y ait pas
un effet fou aux 5
elle va peut-être le seul essai s'est
changé en a eu cinq pour remettre le
cavalier verbe vers des caps mais
quoique y aura peut-être ces cinq à
avoir elle est bien installé le fou ici
elle reprend 2 f
ok pourquoi pas ces cinq quand même ses
positions qui sont vraiment difficiles à
jouer
est ce qu'elle va faire c4 et surtout
prend reprendre elle aussi de f et avoir
une position complètement chaotique elle
le fait la structure depuis on va être
bizarre mais important que les cavaliers
blanc puisse pas vraiment touché les
cases parce que
la casse des si c'est pas possible alors
elle va essayer d'aller toucher h5 et
apsys assez bien joué ça et sur dame 8 à
la peut-être le temps de faire hacker
dame e vita vous pouvez faire fou prend
avec huit cas je pensais 88 d'alger si
ça équidés surtout reprendre faire fou
prend et devenir colmater avec la dame
pour pas laisser le cavaliere rentré en
tout cas pas facilement cavaliers
prendre 4 elle sacrifie elle sacrifie et
elle menace dame j'ai six cavaliers h5
et sur dame 8 ya peut-être eu des saints
qui arrive à la salle r ça a l'air de
céder pour pour la joueuse russe
elle revient un peu dans le match irina
elle revient un peu dans le match
tabloïds et 5 ça paraît vraiment ça
paraît vraiment super fort en long fouet
vii sis ou g6 s'est pas encore fait il
ya peut-être cavaliers f5 ici qui
interdit tout j'ai six à cause de calais
prend aux sept cavaliers f5 ça paraît
fort parce que sa menace aussi de gagner
h 6 mai c'est ce qu'elle joue ça devient
quand même compliqué à défendre comment
est ce qu'elle peut tenter de s'en
sortir c'est fou ces cinq jeux plus
logique mais bon là et déjà pris
simplement je pense pas qu'elle s'en
sorte et qui va revenir vers g4
peut-être à fuji si c'est ok d'un prince
et quatre tours c'était peut-être elle
file survie well elle est peut-être pas
qu'est kf5 échec le retour aussi et tan
tan et dames france et 4 mai - peut-être
la tour qui arrive en ces huit vont
peut-être cavaliers f5 échec tu as envie
de tuer tuer quand même un bon café quel
point f cette prise doit y avoir une
idée eux 6
elle va vouloir rentrer sur f7 avec la
tour cette partie là elle joue pas mal
donc il va y avoir probablement tout
reprend f1 tours.fr et damages 5 qui
couvrira h7
bon ça a l'air d'être dur peut-être tout
reprendre tout reprendre à manger 6 dans
damages 5 sur mon nom mais ça m'a l'air
d'être peut-être tour f4 d'enquêté mg6
la france dames 5 échecs croit g8 tour
eiffe cette eau qui a pas de menace
encore et sur tours fc 3 6 dames f3
ouais c'est ça à l'air force ça va se
rate damas trois tours h7 ça me nasraoui
samana sera toujours f7 aidé à madame f3
je pense que c'est fini je crois bien
d'appareils dame b un échec encore wife
de dame prend et non il ya peut-être
encore des échecs là bas elle a encore
trouvé du conte revue elle est
incroyable cette vanina larroy g8 et des
six hockey aya pas touré fuite parce
qu'il ya tout reprend et damas huit
échecs way est donc là comment est-ce
que tu défends d'affaires d'amd trois
dames pranger 5e il ya ça qui en prise
aux six d'ailleurs tour f5 bien joué il
ya fou prend aux trois échecs dames
prend 1,3 d'impro f5 et elle va tenter
le piège n'avait pas de piège en fait
mais avait peut-être vous prendre trois
échecs et fouet f4 et ya peut-être
toujours floues prendre trois échecs
d'ailleurs c'est resté en l'air pendant
beaucoup de coups et fois f4 après saint
paër de sauver la partie
elle va faire fou prend des six
maintenant les deux joueuses qui ont
raté cette tactique incertain
moment et les blancs qui n'ont plus rien
et les blancs qui n'ont plus rien dame b
un échange les dames et ça gagne
incroyable elles ont raté fou prom 3
pendant quelques coups et finalement
quand ça a été joué vanina qui a une
nouvelle fois retourné la situation
incroyable incroyable elle a encore
retourné salon mais elle retourne
absolument tout il ya un tel écart on
voit que vanina joue vraiment tranquille
et elle commence à accélérer et à
calculer en fin de partie à la réussite
systématiquement arnaquer on connaît ça
c'est pas parce qu'elle joue un autre
jour que ça me donnerait le même
résultat voyez quand même d'aller au bal
inna est beaucoup plus forte et c'est
sur mais bon t'as ta jour un autre jour
ça donnera un match plus serré mais
mellal avantage psychologique est juste
bien trop bien trop fort et irina et
irina a juste fait là elle a qu'une
envie à mon avis c'est d'arrêter ce
match d'aller crier un bon coup et
d'essayer de trouver le sommeil
qu'est-ce qui sera pas évident quand tu
t'es quand tu te fait massacrer comme ça
c'est pas évident de trouver le sommeil
la nuit la nuit d'après elle a c'est
vrai que c'est un peu tu peux te sentir
un peu humilié quand même hein c'est un
peu humiliant après il n'ya pas ailleurs
pas l'humiliation n'y a pas de mal à
perdre à une partie d'échecs mais tu
sais c'est un peu leur sentiment que tu
auras en sortie de match c'est peut-être
fait humilier là quand même parce que ça
fait beaucoup à un certain niveau ça
commence à faire trop serre que +10
c'est déjà énorme mais il ya plus 12 et
est vraiment dans le scénario on voit on
voit on voit vanina qui joue à 50% l'a
fait c'est vraiment en mai c
c'est dur
seigneurin
bon du coup ça joue le pion isolé à la
casse ces trois éventuellement pour les
noirs ont pour le moment qui n'est pas
forcément atteignable ouais c'est dur
les mecs n'ont et 3000 ce stream on a
écouté les mecs c'est la première fois
que vous voyez des échecs jeudi aura un
match avec une joueuse française marie
sebag et et vendredi sera 18 heures et
vendredi à 18 heures on commentera avec
maxime vachier lagrave d'el aouina nous
sort une série de 15 victoires d'affilée
une 18ème et je crois que même
mathématiquement tu peux pas jouer 15
parties en bullet for et qu'elle gagne
les deux là peut être mathématiquement
elle peut encore plus ou moins revenir
dans le match mais faudrait tout gagné
la forêt faire du 100% ce qui paraît
hautement impossible thierry j'ai la
chance de jouer contre elle
non des connexions et ouais sur des
connexions peut-être elle pourrait
gagner voilà les bien encore avec les
non je ne sais pas mais c'est marrant
parce que vanina a l'air vraiment de
prendre le truc
les débuts de partie c'est de la cata
pour vanilla
marie qui est française et marie qui est
vraiment française maric et jose
française
qu'elle perde peut-être cavaliers trois
points séparent a joué de la part de
croche qui gagne un pion et cavaliers
ces 2 mai à peut-être d'amd 5 le retour
enfin là il ya un genre de fourchette
mais le truc c'est qu'on peut repartir
en d5 nom est menacé ça elle fera
cavalier f4 maintenant elle veut faire
un nul n'est pas kelly sur cette manche
qui avait six y'avait dame pranger de
maths
bon alors vanina qui a voulu faire nul
mais irina qui est courageuse qui joue
quand même la gagne c'est c'est beau
quoi d'essayer de gagner parce que c'est
dur c'est tellement dur mentalement la
de tenir tel doit bouillir à l'intérieur
est allée des fêtes peuvent s'enchaîner
s'enchaîner s'enchaîner s'enchaîner
s'enchaîner s'enchaîner attention aux
fous qui est menacée foot être le recul
on des cistes à tour qui va venir en ou
la la la tour qui va venir en b1
peut-être en c1 est vrai quoi qu'il ya
ça qui attaque et aussi peut-être tour
c'est un cavalier un hoquet fous ces
deux dames ces six tours b 1
peut-être qu avait lieu cinq maintenant
dams et 7 on va voir
il commence par h3 un petit coup comme
ça un petit coup qui empêche les maths
du couloir un petit coup de quelqu'un
qui sait pas trop quoi faire mais ce
n'est pas forcément un mauvais coup mais
c'est vrai que là les blancs encore un
pion - position est très difficile les
gens feront leur faire à 5 à 4 à 3
envoyer leurs pions qui a eu 5 qui crée
vraiment rien il ya dames c'est cette
direct elle fait tourbe et 3,4 ce qui va
y avoir cavaliers 5o adams et sept
cavaliers pro f cet or qu'est-ce qu'elle
a prévu comme truc à ryadh ahmed trois
échecs et fou prend est fou prend 1,4 à
les forces est vanina elle a fini par
trouver par trouvé la tactique qui tue
aïe aïe aïe elle a toujours un piège d'
avance toujours un piège davance pour
pour vanina et l'a peut-être faire damas
huit maintenant j'ai trois elles
consolident je pense ça va partir à huit
avec la dame
ouais pour aller s'en prendre aux pions
ces six cordes à 6 pardon fait un petit
échec dame hui 3g 5 h 4 maths mais il ya
le roi qui repart là bas mais du coup il
ya kg 4 le roi qui va venir en g2 dames
qu'à 3 h 2 c'est ce qui va se passer
n'ont pas droit h 2 alors est ce que les
plans peuvent maths et non les noirs qui
vont faire tourner un roi j'ai deux
dames 5
la dame surveillance et 6 pour couvrir
qui herrina qui veut faire annuler
bah je pense que ça va faire nul
l'ancien qui aurait pu tenter d'être
s'être un peu un peu plus les bons
étaient tellement mal un moment donné là
ça va faire un nul c'est sûr je skie
joue un petit peu mais je ne vois pas
comment ça pourrait en être autrement
moins la finale de pions c'est peut-être
la seule
ouais alors attends ça c'est des gueuses
qu'elle est en train de faire h
non ça va être nul ça va quand même être
nul ou pas ouais ça c'est nul avec le
pion angers 5 kg 4 nuls parce que quand
on prend en f 5 ans quand on va prendre
l'eau pure il va y avoir il va y avoir
aux positions et donc ça va faire nul n
était pas loin de la perte quand même un
retour trois pions compte-tours trois
pions par mais c'est ça qui est quand
même incroyable c'est que ça c'est des
finales normalement pas même avec deux
pions tu dois faire nul facilement et
elle n'est pas passée loin de la perdre
elle est vraiment pas passé loin de la
perdre il reste une partie endroit plus
sain toujours douze points d'écart c'est
vraiment tendu c'est vraiment incroyable
le concordat dessus on revoit 1 0
revient à zéro et complètement c'est
vraiment incroyable ce massacre
c'est vraiment incroyable
j'ai pas j'ai pas les mots quoi bon le
roi en f1 mais mais d'un autre côté des
blancs qui ont la paire de fous qui ont
la tacc une nouvelle fois irina qui est
pas trop mal sorti d'ouverture 7 e 5 va
être jouée mais un tournant seulement
l'impression que que vanina va tout
envoyer mais c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment incroyable
bon alors comment est ce que les blancs
vont procéder peut-être tourache trois
tours j'ai 3 mais surtout rage croyais
avoir eu cinq qui doit la gêner et tour
h4 tu te ça mène à rien donc les blancs
qui vont devoir s'organiser se
développer là les noirs qui sont encore
mal ce qui est des femmes à plus de 2000
sattouf judit polgar monde et le
greffier 40 ans voudra pas si tu
t'enflammes pas autant des puces pour
les bus là dedans mais je veux pas
m'enflammer là le monde du sud ne fera
pas ressortir ton talent de
commentateurs de l'as parti d'assez l'os
et chez costa mesa c'est là oui il a
bien sûr là je vais pas pouvoir m'en
flammes et du tout même
rien a enflammé la il
la question c'est est ce que tu vas te
faire humilier en perdant 2 20 points ou
est ce que tu vas réussir avant notre
matière à 10 points communs price comme
au foot est ce que tu vas perdre 4 0 est
ce que tu vas perdre 8 0 c'est un peu la
seule question du truc ça rappelle un
peu un genre de brésil allemagne en demi
finale de coupe du monde super man 2 et
la question c est ce qu ils vont peu ici
en prendre 7 8 10 tu vois je regardais
le match jsk on va arriver à 10,0 tu
vois pas 10 1 ou à 10 quelque chose
c'était vraiment la question du match là
c'est un peu pareil
qu'est ce qu'a prévu sur fous ces 5 j'en
sais rien
c'est clair le brésil à pas de chance un
bon mais là elle va gagner quand même
irina j'imagine mon âme b2 elle défend
rien du tout parce qu'on peut faire fou
prend la fuite
il n'ya pas d'un problème de puisque la
tour aura disparu et maintenant on peut
jouer même juste tour f3 on se doublent
les pions mais ça devrait aller mais je
pense qu'elle va pas le faire elle va
faire f3 et tour g3 et machin risque
elle va encore craqué est-ce qu'elle va
encore craqué
est-ce qu'elle va est ce qu'elle va
encore craqué à lever tour f3 alors
maintenant question c'est ce qu'elle va
se prendre un crédit sur f 4l va se
faire mater allez moi j'ai envie de dire
vanina gagne allez les mecs on se fait
des paris qui pensent que vanina va
quand même la gagner moi je pense
qu'elle va quand même la gagner à mon
avis on est parti pour une nouvelle
victoire de vanina dans cette partie
irina qui réfléchit qui craquèle à elle
a plus le mental a plus rien elle est
allée plus en capacité de faire quoi que
ce soit elle est plus en capacité de
faire quoi que ce soit elle va perdre
c'est sûr dans mon avis c'est sur ce
site et sur quels frais d'amd de l ve
fou b5
ça se sent ça sent qu'il ya un piège qui
va passer un jour ou l'autre mais d'un
t2 c'était pas forcément mais un bon
coup elle tente que des pièges pas c'est
génial c'est devenu ccc c'est devenu une
bouillie de d'échec
ça joue les pièges qu'elle retourne ça
passe toujours pas d'ailleurs dam des
deux je pense qu'elle va les prendre le
truc avec quoique est ce qu'elle va
faire cavalier prend elle peut hein
elle va mettre la demande des deux
maintenant et sur d'amd me 3f cet essai
raté un peu mon cas ma fille si c'est un
maître laurent f7 et c'est pour ça que
j'aimais bien la dame en d2 mais bon ça
semble tenir pour le moment pour les
noirs fou h7
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup
bon ok elle peut pas prendre parce qu'il
ya prise là mais bon le fourrage 7 est
plus que bizarre 1,5 et allait tomber
je vous ai dit vanina avoir encore la
gagner c'était sûr elle retourne tout ce
qui à leur tour de tout ce qui bouge
donc ça fait combien ça fait plus 13 ça
fait treize points d'écart les amis
c'est le massacre le massacre à la
tronçonneuse
là c'est si je suis pas quel film
d'horreur s'aimer mais bon c'est du
jamais vu quoi c'est impressionnant bon
sur ce les mecs une petite pause
s'impose on revient dans cinq minutes a
tout de suite aimé
[Musique]
pour les mecs on est de retour
ça va repartir les deux joueuses sont
revenus et donc ça va partir ou le
bullet ccnmi trois et demi et ça va ça
va repartir pour 30 minutes
allez c'est reparti il ya treize points
d'écart alors déjà on va s'amuser avec
le premier truc c'est de savoir à quel
moment
ça va être mathématiquement finit donc
13 points lie à 28 minutes 40 à jouer
ils ont ils ont enlevé et demi ils ont
grugé une minute quand même ils sont
dits oui on va enlever du temps j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont grugé un petit
peu de temps sur sur le chrono sage et
je rêve pas ça pas commencer à 30
minutes se dit oui on va enlever une
minute war on va abréger les souffrances
donc ouais on va faire votre petit jeu
de savoir à quel moment ça va être fini
mathématiquement sa vraie savait pas
duré longtemps parce que j'ai
l'impression que l avait déjà tellement
de mal
crush apte à tenir la vitesse à se
rendre fou j'ai cinq tours d un ca
pourrait rapidement faire +14 fou g5 qui
arrive quand même chez pascal a prévu
pour défendre dame 10,6 à tour qui
arrive en d1
elle peut pas faire d'alger 6 en corse
qui a prises et a pu lancer cette qui
tombe fou aussi ce alors y'a rien qui
gagne pour le moment
ok à tour prendre des quatre fous hausse
est quand même qui a l'air assez sympa
ou alors on fait le beau jeu ont fait
cavaliers six échecs puis on prend fou
prend mais y'aura dame f4 encore qui
couvrira bon valinakis fait plaise 1
j'ai l'impression qu'elle en roue libre
total alors peut-être fausse 5
intermédiaire mais adam g41 du coup elle
fait fou prend des 4 mai après ce faux
procès quatre ici mais fou ou cinq
maintenant parce qu'il ya plus fous il
ya plus d'âme g4 donc et même faire dame
prend le cas très bien joué c'est du
grand n'importe quoi c'est ce parti
vanina qui en roue libre total chanson
qu'elle a rien calculer elle va pouvoir
bientôt abandonnée elle va peut-être
tentés dame g5 d'alger si souvent c'est
complètement fini mais qu'elle n'a pas
trop calculer un certain que ça pas trop
calculer il ya une tour de moins mais
c'est de lutter tant des trois c'est
bien joué c'est interdit tours détours
ton g3 je sais pas dans quel monde les
blancs peuvent gagner ça il ya une
tournette de moins mais on va voir on va
se laisser guider va cesser guidé par
vanina comme en hamac salle va faire f
travail adam pranger de m'attendre
bon là c'est le niveau de concentration
des joueuses en tout cas de vanina est
au point mort
il reste 26 minutes de match il va quand
même falloir que l'on gagne une ou deux
surtout les bullet pour s'assurer de la
victoire mais là c'est face à ce voyez
que ça se sentait dans le jeu que le
niveau de d'implication était était
vraiment relativement faible pour vanina
mais qui a fini quand même par par
l'emporter
papa qui a été acquis vient d affaires
du pardon qui aurait quand même pu finir
par l'emporter ça avait fait froid g4 je
sais pas on aurait pu penser que thierry
n'a là encore craqué mais non c'est pas
le cas bon maintenant il ya plus de
douze points d'écart entre guillemets
voir comment ça va
comment ça va évoluer et h7 ça sur
cagnes en kg 5
bon alors ne vous ne ne vous méprenez
pas sur les loups en bullet s'est déjoué
ce qu'ils doivent pas énormément joué
donc ça se peut qu'elle faisait que très
très peu de parties on mettra par
habitude la redonne gagnante web alors
des 3 kg 5 baies 5 allée s'attaque à un
endroit il ya peut-être tours à huit la
non pensée à des gets mais avait tour à
huit matchs en 1 williams attendent un
qui a été ratée ici pour les blancs
vahina qui l'a vu après on essaie quand
même rester pas mal c'était mathon 3
quoi ça allait donner tour dames mais
bon
ces héros nettement là c'est un peu
c'est un peu dur a commenté aussi parce
que bon hein implications en termes de
concentration et nul le niveau de jeu
est quand même assez faible quand tu
arrives à rater des matchs en main sur
les deux premières parties là en plus
c'est matmat en un raté mutuellement par
les deux joueuses
c'est quand même
c'est quand même un peu moyen quoi c'est
quand même un peu moyen voilà sa rentrée
dans la finale complètement gagnante
pour les blancs mais peut-être pas si
simple simple en bullet cavaliers c'est
toujours dangereux
tarifs 4 maintenant pour tous défendant
f3 mais qui défend tout aussi le 4
attention à quel point f3 et chaque
équipe rendent et 4 elle va le voir
faire f5 avec les noirs h5 alors exister
pour f4 peut-être non mais ça va gagner
car il y aussi ce qu'est francis bels
surtout reprend 1,3 et afu price est
malheureusement ça se fait quand même
trois pions - c'est un peu tourner la
pendule et irina qui va réussir à
revenir à moins à moins 11
ok l'attenté le match en un nouveau mât
du couloir s'est pas passé je sais pas
dans quel monde on défend ça mais bon
elle va tenter de toute façon c'est dans
son intérêt de laisser tourner la
pendule mairesse ja plus que 22 minutes
de jeu dont qu elle peut en fait en
réalité elle peut perdre toutes les
parties a quand même un pion qui file à
c'est peut-être dans ça reste très
facile
c'est peut-être plus aussi facile que ça
l'a été
à 17 je pense pas que ce soit bon
maintenant la tour défend latéralement
le pion et je pense pas qu'elle se soit
rendu service comme ça elle sait pas
vraiment facilité la tâche elle perd
encore un pion irina qui a plus qu'un
pion de plus et qu'elle trois pions de
plus au début on a plus qu'un et ça
c'est nul théorique maintenant dommage
d'avoir raté cette finale qui était
quand même pas très compliqué à gagner
c'est incroyable franchement trois pions
de plus quand même mais rien n'est fait
encore dans cette partie qu'elle rentre
dans cette finale la prends l'opposition
elle va suivre le roi blanc ou encore le
suivre au café recettes
trois des six comme à l'école et la roi
aux 7es roi f c'est tour arrive c'est 3g
c'est tout tient peut-être que jouer
n'importe quoi c'est nul et à la tenue
un mal gré mal gré les trois pions de
moins ok ça fait que nul tu qu'on
s'approche de la victoire mathématiques
se fasse plus que 21 minutes et il ya
toujours douze points d'écart est la
partie la qui avait créé en plus fait
couler beaucoup de temps mais c'est
assez incroyable d'avoir raté cette
finale quand même c'est ce test et
c'était très compliqué à gagner ses
débuts de la remonte à la mjc rida est
malheureusement non malheureusement non
alors ça c'est si nantes assez sympa je
pense avec les blancs pour pour le
bullet surtout un papa que sur tout mais
pour le bullet sympa parce qu'en plus
d'un peu de temps un peu de jeu sur le
roi tu as laissé le pion des 4 tu vas
pas forcément le reprendre mais c'est
dur pour le roi de se défendre à tour
ses seins
surprise de quatre reprises 4
alors reprendre du fuji malines va
reprendre du fou j'imagine peut-être fou
des deux maintenant pour éviter aux
cavaliers de venir en f4 fait pousser
les pions le fou quillan angers7
il faut peut-être reprendre des quatre
un jour ça va qu'est ce qui va se passer
ici
fo prend des cinq intermédiaire il faut
prolonger trois c'est obligé ça prend
bessette faut prendre h-23 h 1 mais
quand on prend bessette et h2 qui
tomberait faut prendre 5 ça perdait
juste une pièce en ligne l'a peut-être
qu'elle prend aussi ses intermédiaires
est intéressant c'était peut-être
intéressant pour veulent attaque à fond
mais bon là c'est complètement gagnant
bien évidemment bien évidemment alors la
pièce de plus réfléchi comment conclure
avec les blancs kaïs et 6
elle veut peut-être tout reprendre tes 5
mai avec cavaliers prend des huit n'ont
su retour des 8es jusqu'à et prend des
huit ans non non on sera quand même
gagné un
là il ya cavaliers e7 est sûre d'armes
français adam prend un f-16 voilà ça
s'est vu ça s'est vu et ça va refaire ça
va refaire +13 donc ce que je connais
vous peur non je connais pas c'est quand
le prochain ce crime sur cette chaîne
c'est jeudi
et sinon on va avoir la dans la foulée
l'aréna l'aréna blitz crime sur ma
chaîne perso dans la foulée de ce stream
là juste derrière en fait on va quitter
ce stream l'envoi de suite ouvrir
l'autre enfin je voudrais vous ferez
attendait peut-être mangé un petit truc
en attendant
il reste combien de temps de jeu mais
reste 17 minutes et il ya plus 13 au
score ça veut donc dire que c'est pas
encore en cas de déconnexion il pourrait
encore y avoir quoi que je crois que tu
as cinq minutes ou tata peut-être trois
minutes peut-être même la déconnexion la
suffire il faudrait bien revoir les
règles tu as peut-être un temps de
battement ou moment donné je sais pas on
y est presque
donc
effectif il m'a l'air fou g3 qui va
arriver faut prendre 6 aldon le fouet
elle va gagner plus qu'à trouver moi je
vois je vois plus rien non plus mais là
les noirs qui sont super mal le fou en
bessette qui est complètement bloqué
c'est catastrophique
c'est juste catastrophique bon comment
est ce que les blancs est ce qu'il doit
faire cailler des trois cavaliers f5
cavaliers f6 échec c'est bien joué ça
puis on prend fou prend et sur pu
reprendre dame prend roy avait fui dame
g7 matt faire wife fuite et surtout
price est elle pourra du coup prendre
essayer de se barrer mayroy fuite
ça va perdre d'une autre manière assure
y aura foot.fr trois points f7 damage
cet échec est d'alger sept matches c'est
d'être là tout ranger 5
mais là il va juste y avoir foule 6
peut-être faut aussi ce damage 5 s'est
pas encore matt ailleurs d'havas shui
d'amener cette machine ça va être mat la
vache trois dames à schwyz où dame g8
dame g7 et dames 17 matt a pas encore
matt parce que il ya 3,8
comment est-ce qu'elle elle défend bien
et vanina ok mais prendre la tour ce
n'est pas la meilleure idée du monde est
fou 17 maintenant au nom au nom mais
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable elle
va perdre ça avec les blancs à
incroyable et la tour prend ses 4es dame
prend d un nom mais a pas de preuves de
la et dams et de maths dans ce quart est
incroyable dames c'est cet échec mais ça
sentait qu'il fallait pas du tout laissé
les noires s'activent et non mais c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable les amis
comment tu perds ça mais comment tu
perds ça
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable voilà
là c'est tellement c'est tellement fou
quoi de perdre ça c'est tellement fou
c'est tellement fou génération qu'elle
peut perdre des trucs elle peut perdre
un + 25 sur snapfish elle peut vraiment
tout perdre
c'est c'est impressionnant
c'est impressionnant c'est vraiment dans
la tête là que ça va plus un c'est
impressionnant prix après la pub surfer
ou de l'aréna bitstream tout ce que
j'avais la flemme de la sphère en fait
j'avais plein de trucs à faire
aujourd'hui je me suis dit que les gens
regarderai le match et puis et puis
viendrait il faut qu'il faut lors et
twitch quoi façon le lundi on s'est calé
ce crime pédagogique du coup j'ai pensé
qu'ils viendraient et qui verrait alors
la question que je me pose c'est comment
est-ce qu'elle va perdre ça c'est un peu
comme dans les films d'horreur c'est à
des personnages tu sais que et qui vont
mourir dès le début et la seule chose
que tu demandes c'est sais pas s'ils
vont pointu c'est qu'ils vont pas
survivre quoi tu demandes justes tiens
comment est-ce que l'idiot là va mourir
parce que c'est tellement codecom comme
type de film comme c'est plus ou moins
elle a été pris de sympathie s'est plus
ou moins quel personnage va survivre et
quel personnage va aller jusqu'au bout
normalement beaucoup de codes dans ce
dans ce genre de film tête pour ses 2es
jouable d'ailleurs laissé fou prend et
et faire du dame prend f7 en face bon
encore de nouveaux biens irina mais
comment est-ce qu'elles peuvent aller on
peut voir ça
6 tam f4 est en train de le pen est en
train de la perdre
ouais et matt angers7 imparable c'était
la question comment est ce que tu vas
perdre
ok rien pas imparable imparable mais
elle se fait raser pas mal de pions et
maintenant le fou qui revient vers eux 5
et là c'est imparable savait pas
exactement comment ça allait fermer
mais voilà elle a trouvé et la main elle
peut se déconnecter vanina qui peut se
barrer le match est déjà gagné
il ya quoi y'a plus 15 bel écart jolie
massacre à la sphère g5 qui a valu au
karaté f5 viva la musica qui là je m'en
bat écoute
demain je suis né participera à l'aréna
habitue ne participera pas à l'aréna
bitstream rivka merci d'être passé et à
bientôt jeudi on espère que mari gagne
avec le même scénario
sur le cac finit sa percée l'essentiel
c'est incroyable nordmeyer moment moi ça
me fait pareil quand je fais les arènes
avec sarah pas bon j'essaye d'en
demeurer motivé sur une deux parties
mais tu peux enchaîner les défaites
c'est dur mais en plus elle a raté en
maths en 1 elle a raté deux matches en
un même c'est ce qu'elle va réussir à
attaquer c'est vrai tellement tellement
dur tu dois être tellement écoeuré de
jouer je vais raser des pions et quand
même à noter que que vanina réussi à
rester concentrée toulon ans malgré le
score est là jamais vraiment lâché et
surtout premier cinq à damas trois
quatre échecs c'est encore horrible
qu'avait lieu de ça me prend est prise
et d'un projet 3 c'est pas si grave que
ça aurait pu l'être va reprendre de
l'adamant g5 faire f 4.5
ça va repartir et cavaliers 3 ok ok
c'est chaud faut quatre des six
qu'est-ce qui va y avoir un fou pranger
deux tours gf3 mon ça avance ça avance
et je crois que f2 ça a marché parce que
surtout reprend il y avait fin dame
ah oui mais elle reprend comme ça ok
peut-être que elle a un peu retourné la
situation à l'efo qu'irina à la face
face le jeu et peut-être la dame qui
rentrent en baisse est tout aussi salée
ça va ça ça peut le faire là à 17 j'aime
pas trop
elle aurait peut-être durant 36 vont ne
sais pas attention demain matin au nom
elle a encore raté le m'attendre aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe mais je sais pas si
elle pouvait l'éviter mais elle s'est
fait contrer et c'est un nouveau mât tân
dung qui passe pour vanina sait le
festival du mat en est elle en passe une
bonne quantité et ça fait plus 16 et ça
fait plus 16
ça fait un gros score ça fait plus 16 ça
continue c'est vraiment ça c'est
vraiment comment comment est ce que ça
va faire ça c'est vraiment ça le jeu
bon on en est ce que ça va évoluer
ouais moi aussi à pérouges qu'on sait
que ça pourrait faire plus 20 ce match
c'est durant ce pitch est de faire plus
ou moins même des talmas axa fait ça
fait pas plus 20 même des tel massacre
reste reste à ce niveau là à +15 +16
mairie c'est un tel score là c'est
vraiment vraiment incroyable après c
était venu pour la qualité des parties
franchement ça aurait pu faire un beau
match mais le problème c'est qu'il ya eu
trop de gaffes
il ya eu trop de gaffes serré que l'an
dernier on avait vécu vécu beaucoup de
matchs de ce pitch est un peu un peu
avec ce scénario
bon après ça jouer mieux parce que
c'était le speech est ce mix et qu'il y
avait des joueurs de haut niveau mais on
a vécu un peu ça bloque ph ça respecte
ça c'est pas comme comme naka ou quoi
qui trollent un peu vont après moi
j'aime bien le côté troll ça rajoute un
peu de piment qu'en fait elle se mit
trolls dans le sang soit la déposition
tellement pourri avec les blancs ça se
voit qu'elle est belle à des poubelles
hamelin peu moins mais à un moment du
match pendant une heure elle a eu que
des poubelles et à l'arnaqué absolument
tout à tour de bras par là elle va
tenter de faire cavalier cette map
puisque cavaliers avec à briouze f5
c'est juste un coup spéculatifs ça sert
à rien en fait
d'ailleurs elle revient en d4 c'est
juste que c'est tellement facile en fait
qu'elle n'arrive plus à jouer
c'est vraiment trop facile pour pour
valentina elle va repartir vers des 5
ça sent qu'elle se dit je vais la mater
quoi qu'il arrive à faire d'un f4 ou
d'un match qu'adam cette force ou 2004
c'était plus malin dans le sens pour
arnaquer mais bon c'est tellement vrai
nom s'est passé pas son jour à irin a
clairement un autre jour il y aurait eu
un autre scénario là c'est un peu le
scénario
c'est un peu le scénario du pire les
apparats 3 la a3 et d'amd six ans par fr
tour 3 enfin 4 elle pousse en vrai
faisant niveau fille d'équivalent vraies
plus ou moins plus ou moins elles ont
peut-être une centaine de points d'écart
là un peu moins en ce moment mais sinon
c'est peut-être une centaine de points
c'est pas énorme
bon comment est-ce que comment est ce
qu'elle va perdre sa banque a bien
réussi à remonter et adam prend 2,5 à me
prends des quatre voilà on se demander
comment elle allait perdre et tour ses
huit matches en 1re à tabac des maths en
vous on est en train de remonter dans la
partie on disait ah tiens elle remonte
comment est-ce que ça va perdre 17
points + 17 mai on aurait six îlots
match bortnik n'a qu'à ça n'avait pas
été le format 7 on aurait un peu vécu ça
on aurait vécu un sacré vécu un speech
est on aurait passé trois heures
c'est vraiment l'avantagé formate du
sport à cet art après on me dit ouais
mais format 7 du coup les matchs durent
pas longtemps si si si c'est comme ça à
sens unique le match en 1h 1h30 il est
pliée poèmes à la rigueur qui est ce que
ça gêne en fait que ce soit pliée en 1h
ou 1h30
je vois parfois pas trop et le loup et
du souci perso ce qu'on me dit ça a
promu mais les matchs machin d'aidé qui
est un massacre s'est vite finir m
ah ça joue mes fans
c'est cool quel drapeau français qu'elle
représente
qu'elle représente vanina mec a une
grosse victoire qui arrive ça fait
recaler des deux qui a et b 3 tc st
qu'elle va doubler une annonce et irina
qui allaient blanc j'ai même plus qui a
les blancs qui a les noirs
l'inconvénient c'est qu'il n'y a aucun
suspense ouais c'est la difficulté
landes de caves truc c'est que c'est que
tu sais que ça a duré longtemps mais là
vraiment je suis d'accord et kanaeva +10
ou quoi ça le match devrait s'arrêter
immédiatement
c'est une torture c'est une torture pour
tout le monde en fait s'ils arrêtent à
retransmission tu perds ton audience
donc des sous
ouais bon joueur qui restait ouverte
ce fan césar siliana finir plus tôt et
tendres alors dit où te casser façon
moins fait des rhinites ans mais je sais
pas je sais pas c'est je sais même pas
comment elle est encore à 6 devant son
écran la rive alors cavalière trois
échecs aidé à me prend elle va tomber
juste en réalité c'est marrant parce
qu'il ya toutes les possibilités pour
perdre une partie qui passe il ya toutes
les possibilités pour pertes qui passa
salle a perdu autant dire rien à gagner
à l'aréna lancer une arena bitstream
verallia rien à gagner
c'est impressionnant j'ai du mal à vous
commentez les parties honnêtement c'est
tellement peut-être qu'elle prend 1,4
l'a peut-être pas fait reprend des
quatre allées on en voit un peu plus
vite car il y avait six l'aréna sera
bien je sais pas si je vais réussir à
bien vous commenter ça mais bon comme
j'avais prévu de faire un stream
j'annule pas mais ça va pas être évident
dans le sens où la ce match on est quand
même allé un peu pour le commenter 20
chf
c'est un peu dur tu joues à quel niveau
- un peu moins bien que les deux petits
qui sont là ce que j'ai 2300 donc du
coup un peu moins bien que les deux
filles par contre en blitz sur internet
un peu mieux normalement matinales sont
les deux plus fortes que moi
ce qui est inquiétant et voilà
normalement quand même je pense sur
internet mais je sens que même chez pas
invalides à la bienvenue elle gagne 23 5
on verra contre kosteniuk d'ailleurs bkt
fou prend à 6 c 4 plus personne n'est
concentré
voilà une nouvelle fois champion de
vanina se met mal et puis après juste
elle se met en mode jeu l'arnaqué je
vais tenter des pièges et ça passe à
chaque fois de façon à l'ope alors un
pion qui défie qui disparaît ça merci
bonsoir quel suspense arrêt pas rater le
match le plus serré de l'histoire d'aia
papillon prend 1,3 et tu peux pas
reprendre ce qu'elle cavaliers c3 qui
reste en l'air nouveau cadeau auquel
appuyons premiers cavaliers de l'échec
attention mais a peut-être fou prend f7
là qui va traîner ou tourcoing et sète
il ya ça qui traîne et la tour des 3
rockets cave a lieu deux échecs crachin
et puis on prend qui part au bon moment
tout reprend j'ai trois c'est une dame
non ouais c'est le cas et tous rêvent 3
bien jouer pour éliminer du matériel à
la voir prendre les flics prendre la
fuite
à dallas prix f1 et ça fait plus +19
alors est ce qui reste encore une partie
non il reste plus de parti ça va finir à
+19 ça finit à +19 ça aurait pu faire
plus de 20 on n'était pas loin du plus
ou moins les mecs
dommage mais à la fin là c'était
vraiment non plus 18 safina 20 ans 24 ça
fait non plus 19 +19 gros écart 1 +19
écart de folie pourquoi jeter un oeil au
tableau donc voilà on a le tableau du
tournoi devant les yeux et on voit que
ça va faire une demi finale un peu choc
quand même avec un duel kosteniuk contre
green in a donc on verra ce que ça donne
ce sera peut-être pas pas si simple ça
sera peut-être pas si simple que ça pour
pour kosteniuk qui est quand même
favorite mais gouny naquit et qui a
montré de belles choses en tactique ou
nina qui aiment jouer ce qui a besoin de
confiance et de d2 forme on sait quand
elle est en confiance et en forme belge
où elle joue tout de suite mieux
donc ouais avoir avoir un match qui peut
qui peut être qui peut être serré à mon
avis ça peut être chaud donc ce qu'on va
faire les amis c'est que je vous met une
petite pub et puis moi je vais lancer le
stream sur la chaîne bitstream à 21h30
donc dans sept minutes je vais vous
lancer ça dans sept minutes donc si vous
voulez je vous laisse quelqu'un mettre
le lien sur le ch est et continue on
fera la petite arena bitstream à 22
heures je vous expliquerai comment vous
comment rentrer dedans et tout ça je
ferai juste cinq petites minutes de
pause et puis et puis on se retrouve à
tout de suite les mecs et je mettrai le
raid à partir d'ici donc vous pouvez
rester ici ça marchera a tout de suite
[Musique]